bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat c'est une découverte
qui suscite à la fois espoir mais aussi
inquiétude il s'agit de la découverte en
septembre dernier d'important gisement
pétrolier au large de la Guyane il faut
dire que cette découverte permettrait de
relancer le développement économique de
ce territoire ultramarin mais cette
découverte suscite également
l'inquiétude des associations écologiste
tout le monde a en effet en tête
l'explosion de la plateforme pétrolière
deep Horizon dans le golfe du Mexique
c'était en 2010 une marée noire serait
en effet une catastrophe pour
l'écosystème guyané dans ce contexte la
délégation sénatoriale à l'Outremer a
auditionné jeudi dernier Patrick romeéo
c'est le président de Shelle France
l'opérateur chargé de lancer les forages
exploratoires ultra profonds une
audition que je vous propose donc ce
matin de revoir dans son intégralité
bonne matinée à tous mes chers collègues
nous souhaitons la bienvenue à nos
interlocuteurs de Shelle France et en
particulier à son président Monsieur
Patrick romeéo que je remercie d'être
venu en personne présenter le projet
d'exploration pétrolière au Larche de la
Guyane comme vous le savez notre toute
jeune délégation sénatoriale de
l'outremer créé il y a à peine 6 mois à
l'initiative du président du Sénat
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Bell s s'est saisi
de plusieurs sujets d'étude notre
délégation planchait ainsi ce matin même
sur la proposition de résolution
européenne relative à la pêche
ultraarine afin de pousser l'Union
européenne à reconnaître les
spécificités de ce secteur de de nos
outres mes à la faveur de la réforme de
la politique commune de la pêche
cet après-midi au projet de prospection
pétrolière dans les eaux
guanaises un autre de ces thèmes d'étude
concerne en effet les enjeux de la zone
des zones économiques exclusives
ultramarines enjeux considérable et qui
nous paraissent de plus en plus imposant
au gré des auditions que nous menons la
délégation a confié l'étude de ce thème
relatif à la zone économique exclusive à
trois rapporteurs dont deux sont ici
présents je tieninette sénateur de la
Guyane et Richard tuava sénateur de la
Polynésie française la question des
ressources potentielles de ces zones
économique exclusive confère à la France
grâce à ses outres mèes le statut de Dee
puissance maritime mondiale et est bien
sûr bien entendu crucial la prise de
conscience des enjeux de développement
liés au à ce potentiel qui se décline
dans différents domaines ressources
aliotiques énergie fossile énergie
renouvelable substances général
stratégique est lente mais désormais en
marche et la délégation sénatoriale à
l'utre ma pouront y prendre toute sa
part les enjeux sont particulièrement
importants pour nos territoires les
projets constituant autant d'espoir de
développement alors que le marasme
économique est partout présent ces
collectivités ultramarines sont souvent
présentés comme des laboratoires en
matière statutaire comme en matière de
recherche mais jusqu'à présent
ell n NT pas récolté les fruits un axe
majeur de de tout projet doit donc de
prod être de produire localement des
effets structurants et durables
permettant une diversification
économique et le développement de
véritables filières les promesses du
projet pétrolier que vous avez que vous
allez nous présenter doivent se mesurer
à l'ône de cet objectif prioritaire les
perspectives d'un dével développement
équilibré doivent également aménager les
garanties environnementales la
biodiversité de nos autres commè
constitue un trésor
inestimable la biodiversité et qu'il
faut absolument donc protéger préserver
sauvegarder les les exigences sont donc
multiples et les données complexes mais
leur nécessaire conciliation est la
condition incontournable du défi à
relever il vous convient monsieur le
président Roméo de nous faire la
démonstration que le projet de
prospection pétrolière que vous portez
répond à ces attentes et à ces objectifs
pour un bon déroulement de la présente
audition je propose mes chers collègues
que nous procédions à CQ séquence
chacune comprenant un exposé liminaire
de monsieur le Président suivi d'une
échange sous forme de questionsréponsse
cette façon de procéder devrait
permettre d'éviter les redoutes les
redites et favoriser une bonne
compréhension
du projet il est bien entendu que seul
les sénateurs présents ici peuvent
s'exprimer en dehors de nos
interlocuteurs de Chel France les se
séquences seraient donc une premièrement
une présentation du groupe Shell et la
jeunesse du projet guanais en 2 la
présentation du projet procédure moyen
calendrier en 3 les garanties offertes à
matière de protection de l'environnement
en 4 les retombées économiques locales
attend
et enfin en 5e position la condition les
conditions nécessaires à la conduite du
projet stabilité de l'environnement
juridique et fiscal et si vous veneez
êtes bien d'accord je voudrais tout de
suite céder la parole à Monsieur le
Président romeéo
Monsieur Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs mesdames messieurs je suis
vraiment très honoré d'avoir de
l'occasion qui m'est donné de pouvoir
vous présenter le projet et puis surtout
de pouvoir répondre aux multiples
question que vous aurez sûrement alors
je suis accompagné d'une partie de
l'équipe euh shell soit en France soit
basé à Cayenne ce qui me permettra
j'espère d'apporter des réponses plus
précises à certaines de votres questions
lorsqu'elles relèvent plutôt dans leur
domaine
d'expertise alors en ligne avec les le
le programme que vous avez suggéré je
vais vous faire
d'abord une présentation vraiment très
rapide du groupe Shell et de
l'historique du projet mais rapidement
parce qu'il est plus important de
regarder ce qu'il est prévu de faire et
les principes directeurs de nos
activités alors le groupe Shell c'est la
plus grosse société européenne nous
sommes un des trois ou quatre plus
grands pétroliers mondiaux et nous
sommes une très très ancienne société
française puisque nous sommes en France
depuis 1919 nous sommes une société
beaucoup plus ancienne que totale par
exemple et en 2009 nous sommes très
fiers d'avoir créé et la société Shelle
exploration production en France qui
porte le projet dont nous allons
parler alors avant de parler de de
prospection pétrolière je vais quand
même prendre le temps de vous expliquer
pourquoi on pense qu'il est important de
parler pétrole à une époque où le
discours est essentiellement orienté sur
les énergies renouvelables et sur le
réchauffement planétaire par exemple
notre activité paraît un peu
anachronique ou passé et je vais quand
même prendre quelques instants
simplement pour vous donner notre point
de vue sur le
sujet lorsque nous sommes société
énergétique faisons nos scénarios
énergétiques à l'horizon
2050 nous nous apercevons de deux choses
d'abord tout ce qui va se passer d'ici
2030 est quasiment déjà écrit puisque
les prod le paysage énergétique 2030 est
le résultat des investissements passés
et qui sont en cours de réalisation
sachant que les projets ont une durée de
vie de 20 30 ans par contre lorsqu'on
s'intéresse à 2050 l'avenir énergétique
dépend vraiment des choix qu'on fait
aujourd'hui d'où l'intérêt pour nous de
regarder à l'horizon 2050 et qu'est-ce
que nous constatons et en ligne avec de
nombreux organismes un que la demande va
énormément augmenter alors en fonction
des scénarios elle augmente plus ou
moins mais la demande énergétique peut
doubler d'ici
2050 et c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas innocent puisque ça veut dire qu'en
35 ans il faut produire une capacité
énergétique équivalente à ce qu'on a
produit depuis le 19e siècle he donc
c'est quand même un défi pour euh pour
nous qui est très important et ce que
l'on pense c'est que la production va
avoir du mal à suivre nous sommes en
fait nous pensons à l'au d'une période
de pénurie
énergétique et qui se traduit par
exemple par par une montée des prix de
l'énergie au sens large et donc faire
des choix de production ou non
production d'une énergie ont un impact
sur cette pénurie et nous sommes dans un
univers où nous favorisons toutes les
sources d'énergie donc le pétrolier que
je suis est un immense supporter des
énergies non renouvelables parce que
nous ne savons pas tout fournir donc
nous nous nous accueillons avec
énormément de satisfaction toutes les
sources d'énergie quelle qu'ell soi et
lorsqu'elles sont non elles sont
renouvelables et bien nous en sommes
très satisfaits mais il faut aussi
produire du pétrole et du gaz et puis
bien sûr on ne peut plus produire de
l'énergie aujourd'hui sans prendre en
compte les contraintes de réchauffement
planétaire donc sans se préoccuper des
concentrations en gaz carbonique dans
l'atmosphère donc n les choix
d'investissement et de recherche que
nous faisons cherchent à répondre à ces
trois points efficacité énergétique pour
atténuer la
demande cherche de nouvelles ressources
pour essayer de pouvoir suivre la
demande même atténuer et bien sûr choix
qui sont faits pour réduire l'impact
climatique et c'est et pour être un peu
plus précis sur les facteurs clés de la
croissance de la demande et bien il y a
d'abord la la croissance
démographique un monde qui passe de 6 à
9 milliards d'habitants forcément est un
appel à la consommation
d'énergie vous avez sur la la courbe de
droite l'évolution de la consommation
d'énergie d'un certain nombre de pays en
fonction du produit euh intérieur brut
vous voyez que la Chine et l'Inde sont
encore à à au début de leur
développement euh économique et
énergétique si l'Inde et la Chine
suivaient les modèles de la Corée du Sud
de l'Europe de l'Australie et cetera
vous voyez que la demande de ces pays
triplerait
facilement par exemple donc c'est c'est
ce genre de de donn qui me conduisent à
vous dire que la demande énergétique
peut doubler d'ici 2050 et vous avez à
gauche de façon moins lisible le mix
énergétique alors en vert tout en bas
c'est le gaz vous voyez que d'ici 2050
c'est en forte croissance en rouge c'est
le pétrole alors la part du pétrole dans
le mix est réduit il y a il y a un
certain nombre d'années c'était
quasiment 50 % vous voyez qu'en 2050 ce
n'est plus que 30 % 25 % donc la part
diminue c'est toujours une énergie
significative vous voyez bien sûr
l'envolet des productions d'énergie
renouvelable mais là l'énergie en plus
forte croissance c'est le
charbon donc tout choix que la nation
fait de ne pas produire une énergie sous
quelque forme que ce soit se traduit par
quelqu'un un jour qui produira du
charbon quelque part dans le monde dans
une économie
globalisée pour moi il est important
pour la France de produire du pétrole
lorsqu'on a un potentiel géologique
pour des raisons de contribution à
l'équilibre mondial de demande
énergétique qui ne qui favorise moins le
charbon et puis c'est important pour les
aspects économiques balance commerciale
et ceeta mais ça je leserai plus tard
voilà ça c'était mon mon introduction
sur les aspects demande énergétique et
production énergétique et la guyan c'est
un exemple du groupe qui investit dans
une
ressource nouvelle pour contribuer à à
la satisfaction de la
demande alors parlons du permis
d'exploration de guyan c'est un très
grand permis de 24100 km² donc il
s'étend de je dirais de de la frontière
du Brésil jusqu'à la frontière du
Surinam sur toute la bande en mer je
dirais qui correspond au pied du talu
vous voyez la zone vert bleu clair qui
est le talu continental profondeur d'eau
de l'ordre de 200 m et ensuite le bleu
profond et le P est sur la
zone
de de pied du talu si vous voulez donc
avec des profondeurs d'eau qui vont
jusqu'à 2000 à 3000
m nous avons forê à une profondeur d'au
de 2000 m juste en pied de ce tu alors
c'est un consortium qui qui détient ce
permis qui est composé de Chelle à 45 %
de la société tulo oil à 27 et demi
total 25 et norpet à 2 et demi et j'ai
l'honneur donc de représenter Chelle qui
est aussi l'op ur du du programme et qui
est donc le porte-parole et le leader je
dirais du
consortium alors ceci depuis le 1er
février
2012 et le permis a été prorogé en fin
d'année 2011 jusqu'en juin 2016 avec une
obligation pour nous de faire un certain
nombre d'activités de forage et
d'acquisition de données seismiques
donc le sens du programme que je vais
vous présenter est aussi une réponse
contractuelle à notre obtention de
permis qui exige de nous que nous
déployons un certain nombre de
moyens alors quel est l'actualité du
projet nous avons donc déposé deux
déclarations d'ouverture de travaux pour
pouvoir mener à bien les activités
prévues une première déclaration qui
concerne des activités de forage donc
nous soumettons à l'instruction un
dossier pour quatre forages
consécutifs à partir de cette année
jusqu'à probablement juin l'année
prochaine la durée exacte dépendant de
la durée de chaque de chaque forage et
de la et du
séquencement et puis une deuxième
déclaration qui concerne l'acquisition
de données sismiques donc une
une un équivalent
d'échographie je dirais des sous-sols
pour là pour acquérir de la connaissance
et détecter des réservoirs potentiels à
explorer alors bien sûr sous C travail
fait suite au travail déjà réalisé qui a
abouti à la à la conduite d'un forage en
2011 et à une annonce de découverte donc
de pétrole en septembre
2011 alors nous
partons nous avons des fondations
solides d'abord l'expérience de toute
l'activité qui a été mené auparavant et
puis nous avons énormément collaboré
localement
euh et donc je l'espère accumuler le
maximum de suggestions et de de
contraintte et de et de demande pour que
ce projet a une acceptabilité maximum et
réponde au mieux à tous les besoins
exprimés nous avons
euh présenté au public l'ensemble des
données d'impact
environnemental donc nous avons opéré
depuis le 1er février avec une
transparence maximum qui a donné l'accès
de l'information aux associations au
public évident et évidemment au service
instructeur et nous avons énormément
d'activités de travail avec les
organismes scientifiques les
associations socio-professionnelles les
associations environnementales pour pour
développer cette base
collaborative alors vous avez ici donc
le Stena ice Max qui est le bateau que
nous avons réquisitionné pour cette
campagne alors c'est ce c'est un bateau
qui est neuf qui qui vient de sortir de
chantier naval en Corée et qui est en
route pour la Guyane il doit être au
large du Cap et devrait arriver sur zone
mijjo
ça représente ce qui se fait de mieux
technologiquement dans le monde du
forage alors c'est le 4e bateau d'une
série donc il est c'est pas un nouveau
modèle mais ce modèle est le dernier
type de bateau de forage conçu et donc
est particulièrement adapté à nos
besoins
anguyan il s'appelle ice max parce qu'il
peut aussi forer dans des EAU froides et
dans des zones glaciires des zones
arctiques ou Antarctique mais qui peut
le plus pe le MO en
l'occurrence et puis il y a en parallèle
une campagne sismique qui démarrait
début juillet
avec ce bateau le MV Océanic Phonix de
la société CGG Véritas qui serait sur
zone de juillet à
novembre donc concrètement nous sommes
en attente d'autorisation qui nous
permettent de conduire ces
activités sachant que nous commencerions
en juin le premier forage alors ce
premier forage est un forage
d'évaluation de la découverte annoncé en
2011 donc nous sommes dans la même
structure de réservoir nous ferons à 4
ou 6 km du premier forage pour contrôler
si bah effectivement si si le la la
couche de d'hydrocarbures se prolonge
voilà pour contrôler pour commencer à
avoir des données sur les
volume bien entendu que la suite des
activités dépend beaucoup du résultat de
ce forage si nos espoirs sont confirmés
on est face à un volume intéressant si
le forage est sec bah ça veut dire que
il faut faut travailler un peu
plus le deuxème forrage sera un forrage
d'exploration là nous ferons à à plus de
20 km du forage actuel dans une autre
cible donc un autre gisement potenti ci
et la seule façon de savoir si ce
réservoir est riche en hydrocarbus c'est
de forêt pour aller voir donc cette
année une évaluation donc construire sur
l'acquis pour mieux en comprendre les le
potentiel et une autre exploration pour
voir s'il y a un autre gisement
potentiellement intéressant dans la même
région et les deux forages qui suivront
seront un peu la la conséquence du
résultat des deux premiers une une
poursuite de évaluation éventuellement
ou de l'exploration d'autres cibles qui
auraient été détecté notamment par les
campagnes sismiques que nous allons
faire cette année donc nous avons nous
demandons de pouvoir faire quatre
forages les deux premiers sont définis
les deux
autres leur lieu exact et leur finalité
sera fonction des résultats de
l'activité
2012 là vous avez ici en vert la zone
qui a déjà été analysée par des
sismiques trois dimensions et vous avez
en violet la zone que nous souhaitons
acquérir cette année donc une zone en
violet au Sud Est qui est en fait la
zone frontalière avec le Brésil donc le
le morceau non couvert
entre le vert et le Brésil et puis vous
avez au nord-ouest une deuxième zone en
direction du surenam mais qui reste
encore loin de surenam pour pour
poursuivre l'exploration du pied du du
talu vous avez à peu près en filigramme
sur cette zone le pied du talu
continental voilà donc double activité
forage et sismique et sismique c'est
important parce que ça permet de
valoriser le patrimoine de l'État savoir
ce qu'il y a en
sous-sol voilà peut-être qu'on peut
marquer un temps d'arr ici pour que je
puisse répondre aux questions sur cet
aspect là pense qu'il y a de des
questions à poser il y a-t-il des
questions chers collègues sur la
première partie non pas de question ah
oui mon chers collègue vas-y
oui monsieur le Président merci de me
donner la parole j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention votre intervention
qui est excessivement intéressante
puisque vous nous dites que on est l'OB
d'une pénue énergétique dans les
prochaines années pénuie énergétique
d'ailleurs qu'il faut relativiser en
fonction du coûte de l'énergie parce
qu'on sait bien vous l'avez souligné que
la plus forte croissance attendue c'est
le charbon moi je suis d'un pays de
région minier nous avons fermé les mines
de charbon dans notre région tout
simplement parce que le coût
d'exploitation du charbon était trop
cher par rapport à sa revente et qu'en
réalité si l'énergie les autres sources
d'énergie voyent leur prix s'envoler
peut-être que les réserves de charbon
qui existent actuellement pourrai être
misees à nouveau à contribution parce
que leur prix d'exploitation serait tout
à fait devenu à nouveau compétitif donc
je comprends fort bien que vous soyez
intéressé par ce magnifique gisement qui
est au dans les au côté de à côté des
côtes de guyan et on comprend votre
intérêt et on peut que s'en féliciter on
peut que s'en féliciter en disant B
écoutez c'est peut-être une façon de
nous garantir une certaine indépendance
énergétique mais on est aussi en droit
de s'interroger on est aussi en droit de
s'interroger parce que
je comprends bien vous nous avez dit
Shelle est très intéressé on a repris
une partie de ce qui était mis en œuvre
par tulo oil et aujourd'hui Chelle c'est
45 % de la société qui s'intéresse à ses
gisements donc très intéressant puisque
vous n' aavez dit fort justement que
vous êtes en France depuis
1919 bien avant total et que si le
paysage énergétique jusqu'en 2030 est
écrit jusqu'en 2050 et les années
passent vite les années passent vite
vous avez raison de faire de la
prospective mais on est aussi confronté
à la dure
réalité
quotidienne or que vous ayez
effectivement le souci de trouver des
ressources
énergétiques nous interroge aussi sur
quel est votre souci par rapport à la
problématique du raffinage
et vous avez bien compris tout de suite
o je revenir je ve en revenir au fait
que
Chelle qui a été en France depuis nous
avveit dit
1919 était quand même la société qui
possédait la raffinerie de Petit
Couronne que vous avez cédé en 2008 au
groupe petop
plus et que aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation sociale et économique
dramatique dans ce secteur puisque la
société que vous avez vendu à pettroplus
Petroplus est aujourd'hui en situation
de faillite et que comme l'entreprise
Petroplus à Petit Couronne avait 550
employés vous savez les difficultés
d'emploi que l'on a dans ce pays et
partout dans d'autres pays européens en
particulièrement mais bienu à travers le
monde et qu'on ne peut qu'être inquiet
sur l'avenir des
employé de la raffinerie dont vous étiez
les propriétaires jusqu'en
2008 alors on ne peut pas ne pas
s'interroger puisquon est dans la
prospective faisons ensemble un peu de
prospective donc vous exploiter et vous
nous dites si après tout on pouvait vous
aider à pouvoir réaliser votre projet
sur le gisement guillané disons comme ça
pour simplifier les choses pour le monde
comprenne
on peut nous vous dire mais quand on a
exploité le gigement de Guyane cuide du
raffinage et ou le raffinage et nous on
est en droit de dire puisque vous
possédez vous étiez anciens propriétaire
de l'usine de peti couronne que vous
savez que cette usine est reliée au port
du Havre paroduc un oléoduc donc pour
l'alimentation de la raffinerie de Petit
Couronne c'est un lieu tout trouvé pour
que le pétrole de cette nappe de Guyane
arrive directement et vous savez
qu'après quand on est à peti couronne
c'est très facile de valoriser et de
distribuer le le pétrole raffiné
peut-être plus du gasoil
puisqueaujourd'hui on sent bien que
la la
consommation de
d'essenceces de super et en a diminution
par contre le fi et le gasoil est
continue à augmenter donc ma question
c'est de dire est-ce est-ce que vous
avez réfléchi à cette situation de dire
mais si on avait effectivement une aide
pour pouvoir exploiter dans de bonnes
conditions le gisement guyanaé on
pourrait effectivement dans notre projet
envisager déjà le de le relier avec la
raffinerie Petit Couronne pour apporter
la matière première indispensable au
maintien de l'activité et pourquoi pas
au développement de l'activité de Petit
Couronne est passé de50 à plus d'emplois
ce qui est quand même un des sujets
aujourd'hui les plus préoccupants pour
nous donc c'est une chose qui qui me je
vais terminer simplement sur une deuxème
question qui est importante c'est que si
par malheur si par malheur que j'ose que
j'ose pas envisager la raffinerie peti
couronne
fermée vous étiez propriétaire jusqu'en
2008 et il faudra bien dépolluer le
site quelle sera votre implication
dans la dépollution du site parce qu'il
est hors de question quand même que la
dépollution du site soit une
charge
exclusivement des collectivités
territoriales du secteur à savoir la
région d' Normandie le la la communauté
de commune de de rouan et de petit
courouronne donc voilà ma question est
la suivante votre projet est-ce que vous
envisagez d'être un élément qui pourrait
per
économique intéressante pour le seeur de
petitouronne où vous avez quitté une une
raffinerie la vendant pettroplus qui
aujourd'hui en faillite avec 55 qui
risque d'être perdu donc notre souci
c'est de savoir comment voulez faire si
vous avez une liaison avec les deux je
je te remercie collègue ven essayer
d'être plus bref plus conc TER mais
monsieur le Président vous avez été
interpellé je parole sur la la relation
entre l'explitation l'exploration en
guyan dans les e guyanaises et l'affaire
de petitte couronn d'accord donc si
merci pour votre question monsieur Leard
donc sur le l'aspect je dirais lien
entre l'activité Guyane et l'activité de
raffinage en France ici on parle d'un
projet qui
s'ilaboutit produirait du pétrole à
partir de
2019 par exemple 2019 vous comprenez
bien que c'est très long
donc on ne peut pas conditionner
l'avenir d'un site aujourd'hui par
rapport à qui peut se passer peut-être
en 2019 sachant qu'il faut que nous que
ce
projet démontre qu'il a ses mérites que
les quantités les qualités le coût
d'exploitation et cetera et cetera est
un sens pour qu'il y ait un
investissement de production ce que
j'espèt de tout cœur porteur de ce
projet mais on parle de 2020 donc il n'y
a aucune relation terme entre les deux
dossiers ça c'est une réalité il est
évident que si c'est un projet qu'on
pouvait faire produire dans 2 mois là il
y aurait peut-être une question à se
poser donc la question ne se pose pas
dans C terme maintenant sur tous les
autres aspects que vous évoquez alors je
peux en parler très largement mais je
pense que ça ça n'intéressera peut-être
pas forcément le sujet dont on parle il
faut bien comprendre que ce terrain a
une valeur foncière vous percevez
dépollution comme un coût en fait la
dépollution c'est un investissement pour
réaliser la valeur foncière de terrain
extrêmement bien positionné dans une
zone d'approvisionnement de la région
parisienne donc donc il n'y a pas de
question de coût de dépollution la seule
question c'est de savoir comment quelle
quelle est la valeur foncière que que le
propriétaire du terrain réalise par des
activités de dépollution et c'est
normalement une activité assez
profitable voilà
euh très bien euh oui tir au
pentin président merci don la parole moi
j'avais prévu d'être plutôt auditeur de
ce qui se passait aujourd'hui mais la
question de Monsieur N m'invite à
creuser un petit peu les choses on
aurait pu penser que Alain nry pose
cette question parce qu'il est élu
éventuellement
intéressé localement or il est sénateur
du du put d'Ô je vous précise que je
suis élu du département de la Savoie
donc je suis pas du tout non plus
intéressé à titre électoral si je peux
dire mais je suis élu de la Nation
et si je veux intervenir c'est que cette
question que pose Anan nie
elleélargit à la problématique sur les
responsabilités sociétales des
entreprises je vous le dis aussi moi je
souhaite que la commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat se saisisse de ce
type de question et j'attends avec
impatience que l'Assemblée nationale
renouvelle ses membres pour que nous
ayons un travail en
commun pour voir effectivement comment
les les grandes sociétés qui tirent leur
activité économique leur profit dont on
se réjouit tous soit lié aussi un cahier
des charges qui soit beaucoup plus large
que l'objet même de l'autorisation
qu'elle demande mais que puisse être
prise en compte
effectivement la nature de ses relations
contractuelles avec l'État mais aussi
comment elle fait face à ses
responsabilités
sociétales et pour ma part je le dis
aussi je j'attends que l'assemblée se
soit
stabilisée pour que nous puissions
collectivement avoir une démarche pour
voir comment ce type d'autorisation
puisse être délivré effectivement à des
entreprises qui prennent des engagements
à l'égard de l'activité économique sur
le sol national et je ne savais pas
qu'alin néie poserait cette question
mais j'étais venu moi vous écouter pour
savoir si vous vous-même allez en parler
évoquer ce sujet mais j'avoue que je
serais très attentif et comme
parlementaire de la
majorité moi j'aurai l'expression pour
que les choses soient claires à l'égard
du ministre qui qui sera votre
interlocuteur pour dire que on ne peut
pas
dissocier ce dossier d'autres présences
actuell ou passé du groupe Shell sur le
territoire national il se trouve que je
vis aujourd'hui de fermetures ou de de
délocalisations pardon
d'entreprise sur mon département et que
la réponse c'est la même de la part des
deux groupes internationaux en disant
mais vous allez faire beaucoup de profit
grâce au terrain qu'on va vous laisser
ne le dites pas trop ne le dites pas
trop officiellement ça a le
don de vous mettre à dos tous les élus
des territoires concerné car au-delà de
la valorisation foncière qui est un
aspect secondaire ce à quoi nous pensons
les uns et les autres c'est au
développement et au maintien de
l'activité économique donc moi je
souhaite que y compris sur les appels
d'offre
oou une entreprise privée a besoin d'une
autorisation publique pour exercer son
activité il y ait un critère de
responsabilité sociétale au moins cet
entretien nous aura permis d'avoir ce
dialogue franc pour lesquels moi je
demanderaiis que la commission des
affaires économiques au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale puisse faire
évoluer y compris la la législation car
on est certes sur une valorisation
économique on sera certes sur un dossier
où on regardera la protection de
l'environnement mais il me semble qu'on
doit aller au-delà et je suis finalement
ravi que monsieur nerry a aussi posé
cette question à l'occasion de votre
entretien monsieur le Président bien
monsur si vous me permettez je ne sais
pas si vous connaissez la société Chelle
mais lorsque vous vous intéresserez de
près au sujet vous vous apercevrez que
nous sommes une société exemplaire donc
je n'ai aucun absolument aucun doute sur
le fait que nos engagements sociétaux
historiques justifieront très largement
la confiance que nous de
gouvernement acte c'est kaaine Kaska
d'abord ou merci monsieur le Président
bon je je les questions qui viennent
d'être évoquées sont
parfaitement fondé et elle vous exprime
la préoccupation qui est celle
actuellement de la représentation
nationale par rapport aux enjeux du
globaux du développement économique mais
je pense que euh peut-être il ne faut
pas brûler les les étapes pour ma part
je ne sais pas grand-chose sur
l'industrie pétrolière et donc je
souhaiterais beaucoup monsieur le
Président qu'on puisse poursuivre
le le déroulement des des questions que
vous aviez proposé pour en savoir plus
et je rappelle en particulier que ce
projet touche à un territoire
particulier il n'est pas n'est ni dans
les ses veines ni en sa voie ni il est
outre mer et sur une un territoire
auquel nous sommes très attachés et et
pour lequel il faut vraiment veiller à
la conciliation des évolutions
économiques et des évolutions
environnementales donc pour ma part je
je souhaiterais en savoir plus de ce que
vous pouvez nous nous dire sur le projet
lui-même et nécessairement nous
reviendrons au question posée par
Monsieur nerry et Monsieur Repentin mais
après en savoir
plus personnellement j'aimerais savoir
par exemple quelles sont d'ors et déjà
puisqu'il y a eu des forrages les
relations que vous entretenz avec la
population guyanaise et ses et ses élus
d'accord bon nous arrivons certainement
à cette question tout à l'heure je
retiens ta suggestion mais tout de même
je veux pas faire de frustrer mon
collègue Charles R
veut intervenir char revet oui de mots
de mots parce que on comprendrait pas
que le sénateur de l'étape puisque
pettroplus est en scène maritime et a
entendu mes collègues n'interviennent
pas et donc bien sûr on comprend que
pour les plus de 500 personnes qui
travaillent là-bas il y a une
préoccupation on s'est rendu sur place
et je crois qu'il y a eu des engagement
de prix me semble-t-il déjà de la part
de de Shell et on compte bien sûr
alors qu'est-ce que ça va devenir c'est
ce que l'on cherche à savoir avec vous
je pense très honnêtement c'était pas
l'objet bien sûr de notre réunion
d'aujourd'hui et que peut-être que si il
y a une exploitation qui se fait en
guyan ou ailleurs que ce sera l'occasion
de reprendre les
choses bien entendu je pense que comme
le disait Thierry Repentin c'est la
mission le travail de la mission de la
commission économique euh de
s'approprier des dossiers comme ça et je
pense que très prochainement on sera
amené à à le revoir et qu'à ce moment-là
on aura peut-être des réponses euh plus
concrètes euh eu et qui prendent en
compte directement ce projet euh mais je
voulais le dire parce que étant m'étant
rendu à plusieurs places à plusieurs
reprises sur place et ayant compris les
problématiques euh je ne pouvais pas
éêtant sénateur du secteur ne pas en
dire un mot mais je compte bien sûr
qu'on y reviendra dans les prochaines
semaines parce que effectivement il y a
des inquiétudes fort justifiées de la
part des personnes qui travaillent
là-bas mais mais si on a la chance que
des exploitations se fassent ailleurs et
que ça permett de trouver des solutions
c'est sûrement une très ce serait une
très bonne chose très bien bien je
propose qu'on poursuivre mais je
permettez-moi de noter avec gourmandise
monsieur le Président votre vos propos
concernant l'hypothèse favorable B guyan
qui pourrait alimenter les raffineries
de France ce veut dire que l'outreom
viendrait développer l'emploi assurit le
développement économique de l'Hexagone
c'était par devenant de de vous
permettez que que quelqu'un d'ultra de
d'outre mè apprécie ses propos h alors
nous allons si vous voulez bien
poursuivre dans la présentation du
projet
euh procédure moyens et calendrier et ce
projet de guyan d'accord ben madame
ministre je nous abordons précisément
les aspects sécurité environnement que
vous avez vous avez soulevé et puis je
suis à votre disposition pour évidemment
pour tout sujet
périphérique pendant ma présence ces
lieu alors il faut bien il faut bien
d'abord comprendre que ce genre de
projet pour une société comme la nôtre
ne peut être
qu'exemplaire la priorité numéro 1 de la
sociétéch et de ses partenaires c'est
zéro accident
pourquoi c'est assez simple à comprendre
je n'ai aucune envie personnellement
euh d'avoir un accident qui coûterait la
vie à qui compte dans le cadre des
activités
anguyan c'est une évidence mais quand
même mieux le dire en plus on sait tous
quel est l'impact absolument dramatique
d'un accident dramatique bien sûr sur
les victimes mais aussi dramatique pour
l'image de notre société et dramatique
éventuellement pour la survie même de la
société puisque les les coûts et les
charges périphériques peuvent être de
nature à mettre en danger notre société
donc quand je dis que zéro accident
c'est la priorité c'est une vraie
priorité ce n'est pas un discours de
façade et je vais vous expliquer en gros
ce que ça veut dire deème point Chezelle
nous recrutons des milliers de personnes
qui qui sont tous extraordinairement
modernes et préoccupés par les par
l'environnement et nous avons notre sein
énormément de militants d'association de
prés l'environnement donc nous sommes en
ligne avec la société et notre objectif
c'est de minimiser l'impact de nos
activités sur l'environnement c'est une
évidence comment voulez-vous qu'on
développe une activité pétrolière en
Guyane si les Guyanais considèrent que
ce projet n'est pas conduit de façon
responsable n pas de sens donc je ne
peux moi-même que me faire l'ambassadeur
de stratégie d'impact minimum sur
l'environnement je n'ai aucune envie que
nous soyons le ur de quoi que ce soit
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire tout ça
par qu'on a toujours l'impression qu'il
y a les gens qui ont des préoccupations
et les autres qui essayent de les
esquiver nous avons les mêmes
préoccupations sauf que nous avons une
responsabilité de mettre en œuvre les
moyens qui nous permettent de vous
assurer que on nit pas d'accident et
qu'on ait un impact minimum sur
l'environnement d'abord nous travaillons
sur ces dossiers depuis 30 ans nous
avons une énorme expérience de conduite
de de ces projets sur lesquels vous
pouvez documenter et vous verrez que
nous avons 20 installations de ce type
qui sont irréprochable et exemplaire
dans leur conduite et dans leur
résultats et ceci est reporté et
auditable sécurité zéro accident ça veut
dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut faire
énormément de
prévention
c'est des standards de conception de
construction de conduite des activités
qui soient les plus strictes possible en
terme de d'élimination des
risques par exemple dans notre société
il est interdit de conduire avec un
portable en service téléphone pour vous
dire que on définit des politiques qui
permettent de réduire le risque nous
considdons que le téléphone portable
entir c'est un risque donc on l'interdit
C cet exemple vous pouvez le dupliquer
sur tout tout les activités qui nous
concernent ici dans une activité de
forage et de prospection
pétrolière il faut des matériels adapté
des puits bien conçus il faut des
barrières redondantes de sécurité il
faut que les équipements s'ils sont
défaillants soi compensés par d'autres
équipements de sécurité redondant qui
donnent une chance que la défaillance
n'est pas de
conséquence par exemple le stenaris Max
a deux systèmes de obturateur depuis ce
qui est absolument nouveau dans le
monde évidemment il faut des
spécifications techniques adapté et mise
à jour il faut que ce que l'on propose
de faire fonctionne et qu'on en ait la
certitude il faut une formation du
personnel il faut que les gens aient les
moyens d'opérer les équipements de
mettre en œuvre les les conceptions et
les modes opératoire par leur connaissan
et leur
expérience et leur qualification
il faut des systèmes de surveillance il
faut s'assurer que tout se passe comme
prévu or en guyan nous disposons de
trois systèmes de surveillance en temps
réel les moyens de surveillance sur
bateau l'équipe de forage sur
place une équipe de surveillance
redondante à Cayenne et une troisième
équipe de surveillance redondante à
Houston aux États-Unis cette équipe aux
États-Unis suit tous les forages dans le
monde et vous en avez ici la photo
donc des gens qui suivent les forages
donc il y a trois perdieux ou trois
équipes qui suivent la même activité en
parallèle la priorité absolue c'est la
sécurité pour prendre le forage de l'an
dernier nous avons nous-même défini des
normes d'interruption des activités
lorsque les courants étaient importants
bien que techniquement nous avions les
moyens de résister à des courants
importants nous avons décidé d'être une
approche de principe de précaution si
vous voulez donc là et ça nous a coûté
un certain nombre de jours de forage or
le retard ça coûte cher mais nous
l'avons fait parce que c'est notre
priorité et puis il faut une culture de
la sécurité il faut que quiconque à bord
ou quiconque qui surveille ou quiconque
qui soit lié à l'activité et les moyens
de
l'arrêter chez nous nous récompensons
les gens parce qu'ils arrêtent
l'activité c'est très important et ça
c'est culturel ça se développe au cours
du temps c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
impose du jour au
lendemain donc la sécurité c'est d'abord
un énorme investissement en amont dans
les standards les technologies les
équipements la formation du personnel la
qualification la
surveillance et la culture qui dit que
en cas de doute on s'arrête bon et
ceci nous a conduit dans notre société à
un un historique je dirais accident
particulièrement
exemplaire ceci dit jusqu'à l'accident
BP
maondo nos efforts étaient
essentiellement orientés sur la
prévention BP Macondo nous a dit qu'il
fallait aussi qu'on fasse beaucoup
d'efforts sur la
partie intervention en cas d'incident
puisque nos risque était minime mais on
a considéré qu'il fallait de toute façon
opérer comme s'il était réel donc donc
je vous a donné en préambule toutes les
raisons pour lesquelles l'accident est
très peu probable maintenant je vais
vous donner je vais vous présenter tout
ce que l'on fait en cas d'incident en
sachant que normalement nous ne
l'utiliserons
jamais alors le deuxième aspect c'est
l'environnement alors il y a une
première il y a deux types d'activité il
y a une activité sismique donc
d'acquisition de données par
une technique on fait éclater une bulle
d'air qui génère des ondes acoustiques
réverbérer et la
l'image je dirais de réverbération et
comme une échographie donc donne une une
image du
sous-sol donc c'est une technologie non
destructive de d'onde acoustique comme
l'échographie on fait éclater une bulle
d'air l'impact sur les poissons et êtres
vivants en mer peut-être considéré comm
inigeable au-delà de 200
m il évident que si vous faites éclater
une bulle d' sur la tête d'un poisson il
y aura un problème
mais 200
m à plus de 200 m de cette activité
toutes les études indépendant montre
qu'il n'y a pas
d'impact je parlais des et puis il y a
bien sûr des animaux qui sont sensibles
au bruit hein les stacer pour prendre un
exemple alors ils sont sensibl ce qui a
un très gros avantage c'est qu'il suffit
de faire un peu de bruit pour qu'ils
partent ils sont aussi rapides et donc
peuvent partir rapidement donc donc lors
des quatre des quatre campagnes
sismiques qui ont eu lieu en Guyane au
cours des 10 dernières années nous
n'avons pas constater d'impact
environnemental et nous ferons en sorte
qu'on en constate pas dans les campagnes
futures d'abord par un inventaire des
risques qui a été fait par des société
indépendante et dans laquelle on a
apporté notre propre expérience pour
qu'effectivement on soit sûr qu'on a
réortoyé tous les impacts possibles de
façon à avoir des mesures de de de de
réduction de cet impact et donc nous
mettons en œuvre des mesures
préventives par exemple des observateurs
d'animaux marins euh indépendant bien
sûr des équipements de contrôle
acoustique qui permett de détecter s'il
y a par exemple des des des
CAC des procédures spécifique pour
démarrer les opérations très
progressivement en faisant des bruits
légers plus de plie au niveau sonore
requis par l'activité et puis bien sûr
on s'arrête lorsqu'il y a un
doute c'est la c'est ce qui se fait de
partout dans le monde au mieux dans le
monde et qui permet de minimiser les
impacts je dis que nous minimiserons les
impacts et nous le mesurerons puisque
nous nous équipons pour faire des
campagnes de mesure avant pendant et
après l'activité sur sur le milieu
environnant vos activités
hein ça c'était la partie sique
l'activité
forage alors bien
sûr nous avons foré au large de la
Guyane pendant 260 jours en 2011 donc
c'est une activité qui n'est pas
nouvelle nous connaissons très très bien
le milieu pour rester au large 200 60
jours ceci après des des des campagnes
d'analyse
approfondie et lors de du premier forage
nous avons pu mesurer
euh en fait qu'il n'y a pas eu d'impact
sur l'environnement au contraire
l'activité de forage a a été a été en
fait un dispositif de
concentration de poisson donc c'est
devenu un lieu de pêche et
d'attractivité
biodiversité parce que lorsque vous
laissez un équipement immobile dans
l'eau il y a un impact sur la chaîne
écologique planton qui fait que
finalement on a créé tout un
environnement nous connaissons très bien
le problème c'est les
DCP on est plus dans on est plus dans la
logique du DCP que dans la logique
inverse alors il faut minimiser l'impact
environnemental et qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire pratiquement ça veut dire ça veut
dire évidemment des règles très
strictes je vais pas vous faire la liste
mais c'est gros s'assurer que les
équipements fonctionnent que les
équipements de sécurité sont
testés qu'on gère absolument tout ce que
l'on rejetterait en mer qu'on surveille
les bateaux autour qu'on n'éclaire pas
directement dans l'eau pour ne pas créer
de
pollution
lumineuse qu'on réduit les navettes de
bateau de service donc l'empreinte
carbone au maximum de
l'activité et puis bien sûr qu'on
s'équipe en cas d'incident pour réduire
l'impact environnemental d'un
déversement accidentel
d'hydrocarbur alors une chose
intéressante sur la Guyane ce sont ces
courants euh puisque j'entends beaucoup
de choses de part de certains sur les
courants on les connaît bien puisqu'on
les a on les a connu pendant 60 260
jours en direct on les a étudié pendant
des années vous avez ici
euh une simulation donc d'un d'un d'une
nappe d'un déversement accidentel et son
évolution en fonction des
courant présent au large des côtau vous
voyez la bonne nouvelle la Bonne
Nouvelle d'un point de vue gestion et
approche c'est que les pollutions
restent confinées en mer par opposition
au des courants qui amèneraient tout sur
Cayen évidemment donc la la
nature nous est favorable en ce sens
qu'elle nous donne énormément de moyens
de confiner la pollution en mer
évidemment il faut la la gérer et la
combattre évidemment mais en tout cas on
n'est pas dans on est dans des
dispositions de
courant intéressantes et s'il y avait
des vent nord- sudud qui pousserait la
nave vers la côte les courants sont
suffisamment forts pour que ça nous
donne beaucoup de temps
d'intervention alors j'ai parlé de la
prévention donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
en cas de de de déversement d'abord la
la tactique c'est de la contenir sur le
lieu de l'épendage de la gérer proche de
la source pour que les les effets
négatifs soient concentrés sur une zone
la plus réduite possible et puis bien
sûr il faut interrompre la fuite al si
c'est un déversement
accidentel un saut d'hydrocarbure jeté à
l'eau bon c'est facile si c'est une une
perte de contrôle d'un pu il faut
s'équiper pour arrêter la fuite voilà
les
confinement de l'
naapolage et extinction de la fuite à la
source ce sont les deux principes je
dirais de conduite des opérations de
lutte contre une pollution
éventuelle
alors la plupart des pollutions liées à
ces activités sont des petites
pollutions c'est par exemple un navire
de
service qui qui où il y a une fuite lors
de de son avitaillement F par exemple
donc quelques dizaines de litres par
exemple épendu au moment de de
laavitaement ça c'est donc on est
équipé pour pouvoir contenir ce genre de
de pollution faible en quantité et ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle les les
situations à intervention immédiate où
la pollution est est faible en contenu
et nous avons tous les moyens pour la
traiter immédiatement
alors nous avons vous voyez que nous
disposons d'un certain nombre de moyens
d'intervention immédiat navire en
permanence
équipé pour intervention moyen humain et
matériel il y a bien s des moyens mat
sur le bateau de forage sur les bateaux
de service positionn à
Cayen et puis évidemment mobilisable de
plus loin au besoins
et le I MAX le ST max un double deux
systèmes d'obsurat deuis qui permettent
d'interrompre une fuite à la source le
gé après si la fuite est plus importante
il faut s'organiser pour qu'on puisse
amener les moyens qu'on
consomme en permanence contenu des
courants et des
vents le meilleur moyen de confinement
de la NAP c'est l'utilisation de
dispersant donc des molécules des
dispants non toxiques qui permettent de
casser les molécules d'hydrocarbure et
qui permettent d'éviter que la NAP
voyage évidemment ce sont des mat ce
sont des produits qu'on disperse et
qu'il faut être capable de refaire le
plein donc une grosse partie de la
stratégie d'intervention c'est de la
logistique d'approvisionnement pour
ramener les les ces produits dont on a
besoin pour
disperser et là il y a donc avion C130
atrinid et à Cayen il y a d'autres
navires de soutien et il y a des
moyens à Georgetown et à trinidat qui
sont également mobilisables pour assurer
la continuité de l'approvisionnement des
produits et matériels dont on a
besoin et puis après si on rentre dans
le casre d'une
d'une d'une situation extrêmement
extrême extrême il y a bien sûr tous les
moyens
mobilisables dans la région alors région
c'est golf du Mexique jusqu'au Brésil et
depuis l'Europe et
cetera alors je vais pas plus parce que
je pense que vos questions permettront
d'apporter d'éclaircir les nombreux
points laissés dans l' merci Madame
marchambou merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur Merci de de vos
explications
euh ceci dit je enfin à ce stade à ce
stade moi je je ne suis je ne suis pas
rassuré je ne suis pas convaincu je suis
sénatrice de sensani donc très loin de
la Guyane mais je m'exprime aussi en
tant que parlementaire national euh
plusieurs choses d'abord concernant les
risques alors petit risque gros risque
jusqu'à la
catastrophe possible euh vous vous vous
niz pas qu' puisse exister je comprends
vous pouvez pas
nier n nier la réalité vous vous avez
sans doute connaissance de l'Ave du
Conseil économique et social
environnement mental de mars 2012 qui
vient d'être adopté sur la sécurité des
plateformes pétrolières en
mer cet avis rappelle que depuis
1976 il y a eu une douzaine d'accidents
majeurs c'est c'est c'est l'ffit
et il soulligne que le cadre juridique
est encore très très incomplet aussi
bien au plan international qu'au plan
européen qu'au plan qu'au plan interne
et et surtout cet avis fait un certain
nombre de de préconis
je je alors je ne les énumérerai pas
toutes et je pense qu'au Sénat nous
aurons l'occasion de les entendre et de
d'entendre des membres du du C et puis
de les retravailler mais je voudrais
vous interpeller sur quelques-unes de
ces préconisations et
notamment concernant l'exploration
préalable puisqu'on en est
là le Conseil économique social et
environnemental demande de mettre en
œuvre le principe de participation du
public tout au long des procédures
d'attribution des titres et des
autorisations d'appliquer ce principe en
amont la prise de décision lorsque
toutes les options sont encore
envisageable de recourir à une tierce
expertise c'està-dire que que vous-même
fassiez des expertises c'est normal
c'est c'est c'est logique mais que du
point de vue de l'intérêt général par
ailleurs il y ait une expertise
indépendante vu les
enjeux ça ça me paraît vraiment
nécessaire et c'est c'est la vie du du
Conseil économique et social et
environnemental de point de vue les
informations que j'ai euh selon les
informations que j'ai ce n'est pas ce
processus qui qui est engagé aujourd'hui
certes il y a eu quelques réunions
d'information du public d'information
mais ce n'est pas la même chose que que
que
l'association de la population des
associations des élus à la sur le fond
sur le fond du du dossier et il y a
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de d'ONG de
réseau de personnes qui se sont regroupé
qui ont qui ont écrit qui n'ont qui ont
écrit notamment à Monsieur le Préfet qui
n'ont jamais eu de de réponse et qui ne
sont pas
convaincus qui estiment que les risques
encourus sont sont énormes qui pensent
que les les les moyens en cas de
catastrophe les moyens intervention ne
sont pas à la hauteur qui n'ont pas
envie en plus de de jouer cette
catastrophe et qui souhaitent être
consulté ainsi qu'on le dit pendant tout
le processus et c'est consulté je fais
la différence entre consulter et
informer ça c'est la première chose ma
deuxième interpellation porte sur la
question suivante plus générale je je ne
sais pas combien vont coûter ces ces ces
ces recherches et ces premiers travaux
exploratoires mais tous ces
investissements qui sont qui sont énorme
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il pourrait être
plutôt mis dans des énergies du du du
futur plus plus plus sûr d'abord dans
dans tout ce qui peut être efficacité
énergétique c'estàd dire économie
d'énergie mais aussi des énergies
renouvelables diverses qui qui qui
existent aujourd'hui dans lesquels il
est besoin de d'investir qu'il s'agisse
de biomasse de solaire d'éolien enfin je
pense que la Guyane est assez bien placé
troisièmement si la biodiversité était
atteinte ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
mes collègues tout à l'heure ont posé la
question sur plan économique économique
et social c'est bien les des
conséquences économiques et sociales
catastrophique qu'on aurait je suis
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales et je pense que alors quand on
connaî l'importance de la pêche dans
dans la vie des de la population locale
pas
seulement d'un point de vue élémentaire
mais tout ce que ça recè comme potentiel
d'activité
économique et plus généralement des
ressources de la faune de la flore je
pense que c'est une question très très
importante et encore une fois avec des
conséquences économique et sociale
possible très très forte en terme en
terme aussi d'emploi donc sur sur un
plan social alors vous avez dit parce
que par exemple vous avez dit ce sont
des petites pollutions mais on sait bien
ce que c'est petite pollution plus
petite pollution plus petite pollution
ça fait plus des petites pollutions on a
le même problème dans T dans tous les
secteurs on peut poser la enfin vous
voyez donc à ce stade moi il me sembleon
a besoin beaucoup de d'être rassuré
écoutez je vais pouvoir porter un
certain nombre de réponses d'abord sur
l'aspect j'en prends un point l'aspect
consultation information ça fait un an
que je fais des réunion avec les
associations environnemental de guyan et
j'ai deux types de réaction il y a ceux
qui et je les ai invité à participer à
la conception de nos de nos de nos
systèmes à l'élaboration de nos plans la
la réaction ça a été non on ne veut pas
être
coresponsable donc je les ai invité à
travailler avec nos équipes sur les
mêmes sujets que nos
équipes alors pour donc pour vous dire à
quel point nous serions absolument ravis
d'avoir ces gens-là qui amènent leur
énergie positive au service du projet
donc j'attends toujours une association
a claqué la porte dans la commission de
suivi et de concertation scientifique
que nous avons initié justement pour
développer les connaissances qui
permettent de traiter des sujets
d'impact sur
le la biodiversité
guyanaise moi je peux inviter
accueillir mais je ne peux pas retenir
les gens d'accord donc si vous avez les
moyens vous de vous assurer que ces
gens-là veulent avec nous je serai le
premier intéressé et ravi de ça car
croyez bien que notre propos je vous
l'ai dit c'est impact minimum donc si
des gens ont des idées sur la
minimisation des impacts leurs avis sont
les
bienvenus deuxièmement sur l'aspect
investissement je vous ai dit qu'on est
en situation de pénurie énergétique nous
pensons et nous pouvons vous le
démontrer si vous m'en donnez le temps
dans une autre instance donc je
j'accoille avec énormément de de de
satisfaction et de joie le fait qu'il y
ait des investissements dans les
énergies rouvelables on n'est pas dans
un monde où tout est mutuellement
exclusif il faut faire et les
investissements dont vous parlez à
beaucoup plus grand l'échelle et les
nôtres parce que si vous me demandez de
choisir moi entre la misère économique
la misère énergétique et la misère
climatique je sais pas choisir la misère
les deux sont terribles donc faites en
sorte que vous ayez et les
investissements dont vous rêvez et que
vous nous laissez faire des
investissements responsables qui
permettent de réduire ce risque de
pénurie énergétique
donc nous ne sommes pas créateurs de
blocage sur le développement de quoi que
ce soit en terme d'énergie je ne milite
pas contre aucune énergie j'encourage
toutes les énergies alors que d'autres
qui parce qu'ils souhaitent développer
le solaire sont antipétrole moi je suis
pro pétrole c'est mon métier mais je
suis pro éolien pro solaire pro biomasse
et je vous le démontre parce que Shelle
est un des leaders mondiaux de l'éolien
du solaire et de la biomasse mais ça ne
veut pas dire que je ne que je n'ai pas
besoin d'investir dans mon cœur de
métier qui est la insec gazière parce
que le monde a besoin d'énergie et et je
suis dans la situation je vous dis je
devrais être plus heureux des hommes
parce que on s'arrache mes produits je
vous dis non une situation de pénurie
n'est pas acceptable parce que nous ne
devons pas par nos non choix créer une
misère énergétique importance de la
pêche mais je je rencontre les pêcheurs
en permanence nous avons un groupe de
travail sur l'action en mer nous sommes
les premiers à apporter des réponses
structurantes
par exemple pour la création de
coopérative pour la pêche acïenne pour
la réduction de la pénibilité au travail
pour la l'établissement de la
connaissance
aliotique sur le plateau continental et
là où on opère mais les pêcheurs et je
pense que nous sonons nous-mêm gros
consommateurs de métiers de la mer nous
sommes des
marin nous avons besoin de marins nous
avons besoin de toutes il y a des de
formation au métier de la de la Marine
en Guyane qui produit des
chômeurs
alors et troisème chose que je voulais
vous dire c'est que nous assumons nos
responsabilités nous n'avons pas besoin
de la vie du cur pour payer les
conséquences de nos pollutions donc je
vous le dis très sonement Shelle assume
ses responsabilités donc si malgré tout
ce que je vous ai dit nous devions
créer des des dégâts sociaux et
environnmentaux nous serions là pour
aider à les gérer c'est mon engagement
et c'est l'engagement de la société très
bien je vous remercie monsieur le
Président je passe la parole à l'un des
rapporteurs monsieur
Anet merci Président Monsieur le
Directeur pour lever toute ambiguité je
préfère dire d'emblé que je fais partie
de ceux qui considèrent que la
production hfort d'hydrocarbure euh
constitue un enjeu historique euh pour
le développement de notre région on l'a
vu tout à l'heure également en terme de
de de filière on reviendra tout à
l'heure pour l'ensemble de la France
hexagonale ceci étant dit euh cet en jeu
important nous invite à être très
vigilant sur euh le milieu de la
biodiversité la protection de cette
biodiversité euh or il se trouve à juste
titre mon collègue l'a
rappelé l'ambiance en guyan au niveau
donc du mouvement associatif mais
également des professionnels sur cette
question euh l'ambiance démandre que ils
sont exclus des processus de de décision
et à juste titre euh il sécrit dans la
Constitution notamment dans au niveau de
la Charte de l'environnement que la
participation non pas l'information la
participation est indispensable dans la
définition des des différents processus
euh notamment opérationnels donc là la
première question et j'insiste est-ce
que euh réellement réellement les
organisations les associations les
professionnels participent dans cette
chaîne de de de de de de prise de
décision la la la la 2è question ça
concerne la la
gouvernance il y a un rapport
du Parlement britannique de 2011 qui
stipule très très clairement que les
consortiums
pétrolier ont une expertise sur le volet
industriel une expertise sur le
volet financier heureusement d'ailleurs
cependant il y a il y a y a des
défaillances au niveau de de
l'environnement alors est-ce que à ce
niveau la gouvernance est équilibré par
rapport donc à ce rapport qui date de
2011 qui est un rapport relativement
récent quand nous savons tous que il y a
un vide juridique au niveau donc du code
minier qui est actuellement en refente
le code international plutôt donc les
les normes internationales s'appliquent
plus ou moins mais créent des des des
zones d'ombre à tel point que
quelquefois ce qui est proposé
d'ailleurs
quelquefois sont des pratiques
noncentionnel donc il est évident que
nous devons nous
entourer prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour éviter à la fois pour
rassurer le grand
public c'est indispensable me
semble-t-il pour concilier justement les
enjeux du développement économique mais
la préservation de de de notre
biodiversité
marine et également éal également donc
pour faire partager donc euh votre euh
projet de développement qui qui qui qui
paraît assez euh
idillique la la la la 2ème question par
rapport au la trème question pardon par
rapport à au au permis de de travaux
déclaration de travaux qui qui ont été
donc euh déposé euh c'est quel type de
procédés de fourage euh qui seront donc
retenu euh lors de de la prochaine phase
d'exploration vous savez très bien que
lors de la première phase d'exploration
il y a eu un débat entre vos
préconisations et le mouvement
associatif qui était opposé à tel point
queil y a un préfet il un arrêté
préfectoral qui a tronché à ce niveau je
sais que aujourd'hui donc vous revenez à
la charge avec cette fois-ci un avis
favorable un avis favorable des services
donc de l'environnement alors
pouvez-vous nous répondre précisément
par rapport donc la prochaine phase
d'exploration qui qui qui va débuter
bientôt quel type de procédés de forage
qui qui seront donc utilisés d'ici
quelques semaines toujours dans dans ce
F les technique je reviendrai je suis
moi lorsre le le plan du du du du
président sur les
impacts socio et économique ça concerne
donc àon une restitution des des risques
géomorphologiques suite à la première
phase
d'exploration notamment lié au aux
études de comportement de la poche
d'hydrocarbure par prélèvement donc
est-ce que vous avez ces résultats
est-ce que vous pouvez donc nous les
publier et enfin et enfin dernière
question sur le volet technique vous
avez dit de vous a affirmez de de de de
de faits ça concerne le le les histoires
de
courant votre analyse n'est pas partagée
part tout les les
spécialistes en disant
que les les courants sont favorables
donc sont systématiquement favorables à
à à à à la production à savoir donc de
la côte vers le large les les SP encore
une fois mais bon je suis pas
spécialiste mais je je je lis des notes
qui précise non quelquefois quelquefois
et plus souvent que que vous n le dites
il y a des courants contraires euh qui
vend donc vers la côte donc ça
contredirait éventuellement ce ce que
vous venez donc
d'affirmer tout à l'heure et enfin la la
deuxème la dernière observation ça ça
concerne la les principales migrations
saisonnièr de de la faune aquatique bon
je vousi entendu j'étais un peu surpris
d'ailleurs sur les zempes de de Guen
première vous disz que dans cette zone
il n'y a pas de poisson bon j'is un peu
surpris j'is un peu surpris mais bon ça
arrive ça arrive parfois
que répondre rapidement mais bon ça
m'étonnerait que dans cette zone comme
par hasard qu'il n'y aurait pas donc de
de
poisson dans dans cette zone alors là
encore il faudrait rassurer rassurer
donc à la fois les marins pêcheurs mais
vous dites que vous êtes souvent en
contact avec eux mais assurer également
donc les scientifiques sur cette
question notamment par rapport donc au
au tests qui qui qui vont débuter donc
bientôt donc d'ici quelques semaines
est-ce que là vous avez pris donc des
des mesures particulières justement pour
pour éviter donc c ces dégâts est-ce que
vos vos vos phases donc expérimentales
vont tenir compte de de de ces
migrations de de de la faune aquatique
on sait très bien que dans les parages
il y a nos fameuse tortue lut hein qu'on
trouve exclusivement dans cette zone
durant une période de de la saison mais
ce sera durant cette période de qui a
débuté d'ailleurs d'avril jusqu'au mois
d'août donc est-ce que vous allez tenir
compte donc de de ces phénomènes voilà
président et puis en fait une dernière
question mais qui va nous permettre
peut-être de de rebondir alors on a
parlé de la phase d'exploration mais
vous avez quelques idées sur la phase
d'exploitation est-ce que vous avez une
idée plus ou moins précise à quelques
barils près du de la quantité de
gisement d'accord attendu alors je vais
prendre alors souvent je vais répondre à
vos questions dans l'ordre inverse pour
pouvoir finir par la gouvernance qui est
qui est reprise dans le chapitre 4
d'abord monsieur le sénateur nous
essayons de travailler avec des données
pas des sentiments des données sur les
courants c'est un la donnée de
courantologie est fondamentale dans la
conduite de nos activités nous sommes
des marins nous devons connaître les
courants pour faire des conceptions de
système des choix de matériel comme le
stenar max savoir comment positionner
des moyens d'intervention et c'est notre
cœur de métier donc nous ne pouvons
l'engager que si nous avons des données
sur les courants donc nous sommes parmi
les gens qui ont qui avons fait le plus
de recherches sur les courants au large
de la Guyane et nous avons fait
énormément de relevé et nous sommes
restés 260 jours en mer donc les
courants on les a heure par heure au
jour le jour sur quasiment une
année il est vrai qu'il que les courants
ne sont pas 365 jours exactement comme
je vous l'ai décrit mais ils sont très
largement comme ça et il y a toujours la
circonstance particulière qui peut faire
qu'il sont pas orientés comme ça elle
existe mais je ne peux pas laisser dire
à certains que les courants vont
systématiquement sur Cayen quand quand
on a relevé une fois dans l'année par
contre nous sommes équipés pour lo
lesquip courant IR vers Cayen mais si
vous voulez que je vous rassure il faut
aussi que vous que la collectivité
accepte les données en terme de TI
expertise c'est validé par la Marine
nationale par le CRE évidemment tout le
monde dispose des mêmes données donc il
suffit de
exploiter ça c'est de la c'est de la
donnée c'est de la donnée technique
scientifique elle est elle est là et je
suis très heureux qu'elle soit plutôt
dans ce sens que dans l'autre mais nous
sommes équipés pour répondre à tous les
scénarios c'est dans notre inventaire
des risques on a dit bah si les cours
sont pas comme ils étaient prévus
qu'est-ce qui se
passe nous pensons qu' la probabilité
qu'il y ait du pétrrole sur la mangve
est extrêmement faible contenu de tout
ce que j'ai dit mais on a démarré des
des études pour voir quelle est la
meilleure moyen d'intervention sur la
Mang grve même si on pense que c'est pas
pertinent on le fait quand même parce
qu'on essae nous en professionnel de
lister tous les problèmes possibles et
on le fait aussi bien que d'autres et
d'y répondre et d'ailleurs on demande
leur avis aux gens sauf que les gens en
général n dit parce qu'il y a un risque
il ne faut pas faire c'est là qui est la
frontière entre nous et d'autres on dit
parce qu'il y a un risque on voit quelle
réponse on peut y apporter et est-ce que
le risque résiduel est acceptable oui
non et il y a des fois on dit non
nous-même et c'est comme ça que parfois
on a interrompu nos propres opérations
après migration saon la raison pour
laquelle on démarre au mois de juillet
c'est précisément pour prendre en compte
les migrations saisonnières donc le
planning d'acquisition sismique est très
largement calqué sur les
tortues évidemment pourquoi voulez-vous
que je fasse délibérément des activités
au moment où ça a plus d'impact sur les
tortues j'ai aucune raison pour le faire
il y a deux contrainte majeure pour les
activitésmques ce sont les migrations
saisonnières et ce sont les courants et
les vents bon la période que nous
proposons dans la déclaration c'est
celle qui est la meilleure période
possible lorsqu'on prend tout en compte
toutes ces contraintes et ces données
sont accessibles elles sont accessibles
sur Internet je les présente en réunion
publique à Cayenne et j'ai devant moi
les association qui me pose énormément
de questions mais lorsque j'ai dit qu'il
y a peu de poisson au large c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est l'rè j'ai les
relevés par par moi de toutes les
densités sur une dizaines d'espèces et
ce sont des faites ce sont pas des
choses que j'invente
donc on veut être assuré mais il fauti
alors je sais qu'on a pas confiance dans
l'expert ni dans les données mais à ce
momentl ça devient très difficile en
tout cas nous avons les données nous
avons des expertises
indépendantes qui nous conduisent à
proposer dans nos déclarations les
activités qui nous paraissent avoir
l'impact minimum et je suis très fier de
vous dire qu'on va utiliser des fluitesé
de forage qui nous avait été interdit il
y a un an et j'en suis fier parce que
pour moi c'est un élément de sécurité
majeur si on nous l'interdisait je pense
que je n'atteindrai plus mon objectif zé
accident et donc je remettrais forcément
en cause la conduite de nos
opérations c'est une énorme avancé pour
la collectivité le fait qu'on
puisseutiliser dans certain parties du
forage un flu partic adapté à ça et qui
n'est pas toxique qui n dans la
classification rich européenne
donc c'est pas la peine de me dire il ne
faut fort qu'à l'eau l'eau ça marche
souvent et quand ça peut on peut le
faire c'est bien parce que c'est pas
cher mais lorsque je dois utiliser un
fluide synthétique qui coûte une fortune
je le fais parce qu'il y a une raison
technique et parce qu'il me réduit le
risque c'est pas pour le plaisir de
payer une fortune un produit synthétique
et il il coûte une fortune parce qu'il
est efficace pour foret mais il est pas
toxique il est biodégradable il est il
est pas bioaccumulable et cetera et
cetera on a 20 ans de recherche derrière
qui démontrre que l'effet de ces fluides
est de l'ordre de grandeur de l'effet de
l'eau donc pourquoi voulez-vous que je
propose quelque chose qui soit moins bon
qui me conduise à créer des problèmes de
sécurité sur forage quand j'ai une
solution qui est adapté donc je propose
ma solution adaptée les services de
l'État ont considéré qu'effectivement
notre approche était la meilleur donc
ils l'ont
supporté voilà et données publiques
partageable auditable et
cetera euh donc voilà c'est pour moi une
très grande fté faut dire que nous avons
collectivement fait un grand
progrès en ce qui concerne la
gouvernance bah c'est un peu le l'objet
de la du 4e point parce que vous verrez
comment on gère euh ces aspects retombés
et et construction de la connaissance
scientifique et ça m'amènera à parler de
la gouvernance donc si vous si vous me
le permettez je je réponds à votre
question euh
oui il me pas il me semble que vous
n'avez pas répondu à une question
concernant les capacités attendues la
présomption de
capacité la raison pour laquelle je vous
demande je demande à l'état
le une autorisation pour forêt c'est
justement pourouvoir répondre à cette
question
oui nous n'attendons pas une réponse
précise mais nous sommes comme il y a eu
premier fourrage il y a eu des comme
vous avez dit des euh don sismique il y
a peut-être sans vous jeter troup à
l'eau vous Pez me donner des ordres de
grandeur des choses attendu vous allez
pas faire autant d'investissement pour
ne rien trouver
oui il faut savoir que lorsqu'on a fait
le premier forrage il y avait que 10 %
de chance qu'on trouve des hydrocarbur
10 %. et nous l'avons fait aujourd'hui
vous avez donc nous avons gagné notre
Paris intellectuel qui était de dire il
peut y en avoir mais il n'y avait que 10
% de chance qu'il y en est il y a
beaucoup de raisons pour ça
et grâce à VO par nous avons eu le
bonheur de de valider nos hypothèses et
c'est bien pour l'État pour la
valorisation de son patrimoine et pour
les le potentiel économique que ça
génère bon mais la même personne qui a
foré avec 10 % de chance de succès vous
dit que je ne sais pas combien on peut
produire parce que c'est justement
l'objet du travail que l'on fait
évidemment que je pense que la que ça le
jeu envoie la chandelle autrement on
naurait pass se programme sur la table
mais ça ne veut pas dire que la chance
de succès est garantie et justement tout
le problème pour nous c'est plus
tellement la présence d' hydrocarbure
mais c'est il peut y en avoir énormément
dispersé en petite quantité sur une
grande surface surface au sens
souterrain du terme voyez que c'est pas
la même chose que oui un gisement comme
ça je je for ici je j'extrait toute la
bouteille avec un puit à la même
quantité répartie sur tout le plancher
de la oui je vais devoir faire 50
forages pour aspirer une toute petite
quantité oui voilà c'est ça mais non
mais c'est c'est de ça tout à fait
compris cela l'importance de faire les
forages faut faire des forages
complémentaires pour voir l'étendue de
la nappe détendu de la du lac souterrain
et cetera mais nous avons vous avez des
études géologiques quand même qui vous
ont amené justement ce que vousz vous
appelez euh de né culturel en fait j'ai
pas culturel
mais c'est que vous avez des éléments
vous permettant dire dans cette partie
du monde qui une continuité de d'une
autre partie on peut espérer t à peu
près et ça peut être comparable à ce que
vous avez constaté ailleurs ailleurs
dans une roche comparable ce que ce que
l'on a toujours dit c'est que cette zone
était miroir de l'Afrique de l'ouestque
de l'Ouest
Ghana Sierra leéone Libéria donc à ce
niveau de de généralité pr je peux vous
dire qu'il y a le même potentiel de
l'autre côté et ça on l'a validé par le
fait qu'on a trouvé du pétrole mais
maintenant pour que je passe de la de la
considération générale à moi-même
revenant ici pour vous dire voilà on a
maintenant un projet potentiellement
commercial qui peut produire temps par
jour et ben il me faut tout ce travail
très bien on avait compris disons que
nous sommes dans une hypothèse
favorable mais le fait qu'on le fasse
sur des fonds
privé montre que l'industriel à la fois
vous donne pas l'impression deoir la FO
je j'ai pas de certitude j'ai la foi
mais pas de certitude tout à fait si on
vous dit que c'est c'est l'équivalent du
catar est-ce que vous dites non c'est
faux c'est sûrement pas l'équivalent du
Qatar je connais pas suffisamment le
Qatar mais on n a aucun moyen pour dire
une chose pareille
aujourd'hui bon j'espère que cette
question aura une réponse nous allons
prendre rendez-vous à la fin de l'année
c'est ça pour avoir desments plus clair
vue plus clair alors il est vrai que
comme on va faire un puit d'évaluation
de la première découverte ce deuxième pu
si c'est un succès au sens où il valide
beaucoup nos hypothèses là oui on aura
progressé je pense
dans on saura si c'est quand même une
vraie opportunité ou si c'était
bon si ça néite beaucoup plus de travail
pour le gu mais donc oui c'est une
activité où c'est quand même la
découverte le succès de l'activité qui
qui génère la tout à fait connaissance
donc nous sommes dans une présomption
très
favorable on peut on peut dire cela on
peut dire très
bien très bien monsieur collègue ma j'ai
une question à poser
merci savez
ça ça fait deux fois que j'entends
parler des installations comme potentiel
DCP
oui
bien j'ai quelques doutes et vous aurez
quelques vous aurez du mal à me
convaincre je sais bien comment ça se
passe la la pratique de la pêche sur DCP
et je sais également que vos
installations euh de par la loi
nécessite nécessite un périmètre de
sécurité alors comment voulez-vous
qu'avec le périmètre de sécurité qui qui
euh qui provoque automatiquement une
interdiction d'approcher comment
voulez-vous que ça fasse fonction en
même temps de DCP ah non vous avez
parfaitement raison ce ne sont jamais
des DCP officiels je veux dire ou ou les
gens viendrai pêcher parce que mais je
je parlais de l'effet des CP c'est le
fait qu'il y a quelque chose qui flotte
ouinais un effet descp par contre on
peut imaginer que dans le développement
de l'activité en mer on met des vrais
DCP à la finalité de pêche au large mais
ça c'est un un sujet d'aménagement on
peut discuter
ouais bon mais
bon en tout cas il y a un effet DCP mais
pas pour être exploité en tout cas non
pas pas sur la pas pas au la plform
d'accord
donc première conclusion là où il y a
peu de poisson il y en aura forcément
beaucoup et donc le problème est entier
maintenant parce que même si vous
installez là où il y a pas du tout mais
vous en aurez beaucoup donc faudra
penser à les protéger ces nouveaux toute
cette chaîne alimentaire qui va qui va
arriver par vos installations donc ne
vous réjouissez pas trop de l'absence de
poisson puisqu'il y en aura beaucoup ah
mais nous serons ravis de protéger
beaucoup de poissons comenez bien qu'il
y a pas d'antagonisme entre moi et les
poissons pas du tout not notre rôle
c'est d'avoir un impact minimum et nous
sommes d'ailleurs les meilleurs
observateurs des espèces puisque nous
sommes présents et travaillons là alors
je peux vous dire que les les les les
les les je sais pas quel est le terme
les gens qui observent les poissons les
plus les plus passionnés sont chez nous
vous savez il y a pas d'antagonisme
entre une société qui dans le but est
d'extraire et de et de d'avoir un impact
néfaste et des gens qui se disent mon
dieu il ne faut rien faire parce que
faire va forcément créer des effets
pervers non notre approche c'est de dire
on va être là il faut nous faut bien
connaître le milieu pour que justement
on y soit dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
conception mesure de d'accompagnement
des
opérations et cetera pour que pour que
ce soit fait le mieux possible
et puis si un jour nous avons un
développement commercial et que nous
sommes présents là pour 20 ans avec une
installation flottante et bien il faudra
se poser toutes les bonnes questions
pour et bien pour gérer cet cet impact
mais qui là sera permanent par la simple
fait qu'il y a la présence et on voit
bien qu'être présent par l'effet descp
c'est différent absent donc et l'effet
n'est pas forcément négatif c'est un
c'est un effet comme toute activité
humaine génère en effet notre propos
c'est que son impact soit le plus
positif possible là on va parler
beaucoup des aspects très positifs mais
que les que les impacts négatifs soient
le plus faible possible d'où
l'accumulation de connaissance
d'expertise de technique pour essayer
que ce soit le cas très bien je vous
remercie président mais je voulais
parler excuse-moi l'URE avance j'ai une
question très important un point très
important à soulever c'est les retombées
économiques locales attendu c'est de ça
que j' tout à l'heure donc je passe tout
de suite la parole à mon collègue
rapporteur tu Richard tuava merci
monsieur le Président chers collègues
monsieur
président avant avant d'aborder cette
question là j'avais une une petite
curiosité mais très simplement c'est un
petit peu mon des formations
professionnelles sur l'armature même du
projet en fait je me poser la question
de savoir euh à partir du moment o vous
mentionnez que Shelle a succédé à tulo
oil
depuis le 1er février
2012 et tulo il est toujours dans le
projet à 25 % en fait qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé c'est la première chose à
laquelle je me
suis qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à ce
moment-là est-ce qu'il y a eu juste une
succession de de leadership dans le
projet ou est-ce que tu l' l' a senti
peut-être que c'était moins
intéressant bon ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose évidemment
toucher à au retomber au
retomber je je je pense que je serai
peut-être pas là pour la réponse
totalement parce que je vais devoir
prendre un avion dans pas longtemps j'ai
pour la poisie française pour le retour
et je suis désolé mais bon j'aurais
j'auris le contre-rendu des
débats mais je crois que c'est important
aussi de de de hier nous avions eu déjà
quelques auditions toujours dans le
cadre de la délégation et nous avait été
mentionné que le le le le le le pétrole
dans dans en tout cas dans
l'architecture du projet actuel
euh devait être donc retiré directement
sur place au au large et ne ne
transitait pas par la Guyane mais parait
directement vers la raffinerie ou vers
la commercialisation alors je me suis
posé la question vous imaginez bien
Polynésie française CEP
euh centre d'expérimentation nucléaire
40 ans bon des choses sont revenues un
peu à la surface je me suis dit alors
comment les guyanés vont s'en sortir et
finalement quel va être la la principale
retombée pour les Yanis si ne voit pas
passer le pétrole chez eux voilà c'est
très rapidement mais en même temps très
caricaturellement ma
question mais d'abord premier point sur
l'aspect consortium donc le consortium
Chelle 45 % tulo 27 et5i total 25 et
norp or un consortium comme ça désigne
toujours un opérateur parce qu'il vous
faut une face unique vous pouvez pas un
jour tra avec Total le lendemain avec
Shelle le lendemain avec Tul donc donc
le le consortium choisit une société qui
prend le rôle d'opérateur et il est
légitime que celui qui a la plus grosse
part du projet soit de facto l'opérateur
c'est à la fois une une démonstration de
notre engagement et puis aussi c'est en
ligne avec enfin notre intérêt est
démontré par notre participation et par
le fait qu'on est opérateur alors ce qui
se passe et ben c'est que donc Shell est
devenu le leader du consortium donc
c'est c'est
toutes les décisions d'investissement et
les décisions stratégiques sont prises
par l'ensemble des partenaires par
exemple le choix du lieu du prochain
forage c'est une décision
collective le le le la définition du
budget 2012 c'est une décision
collective mais une fois que les budgets
les ressources son définis c'estchelle
qui met en œuvre le projet avec ses
standards ses approches ses
équipes donc c'est pour ça que vous
verrez on parlera beaucoup de Chelle
même si c'est il faut toujours
comprendre le porte-parole du
consortium et donc il y a eu simplement
une passation de de rôle d'opérateur
mais nous étions déjà très impliqués
dans le projet puisque partie prenante
de toutes les décisions qui avaient été
prises
auparavant alors oui toute façon il n'y
a qu'un seul standard qui est mis en
uvre c'est le standard Shelle et qui est
je vous le dis le le le standard de
référence dans l'industrie donc ça fait
partie des conditions d'appartenance au
consortium c'est que tout le monde
adhère aux politique Sécurité
Environnement et cetera alors sur
l'aspect retombé voilà très bien donc
c'est l'objet de du 4e chapit point
voilà alors je vais peut-être passer
très rapidement revu les les têtes de
chapitrre comme ça vous aurez peut-être
des réponses
euh bon il il y a deux choses
dans il y a il y a quatre domaines dans
le le projet a un
impact nous travaillons très activement
sur qu quand je dis nous travaillons il
y a une composante régionale étatique
qui met en place une commission de suivi
et de concertation il y a
qu sous-groupe de travail qui s'adresse
à ces qu sujets Formation
Emploi stimulation tissu économique
local coopération scientifique et action
en
mer d'accord donc ces quatre
sujets font déjà l'objet d'un travail de
fond et déjà on fait l'objet de
décisions qui ont été pris c'est que je
vais vous
communiquer
ça c'est ce qui permettra de de d'ancrer
le projet en guyan et qui a un maximum
de retombé local sur tous ces quatre
axes avant ce long terme il y a le cour
terme c'est aujourd'hui là maintenant
vous voyez qu'on est dans le début d'une
activité
d'exoration de prospection donc qui peut
ne pas durer longtemps
puisque résultat des activités futures
conditionneront le volume de
travail mais nous essayons d'ors et déjà
de d'assurer le maximum de retombé local
par l'ouverture d'appel d'offre aux
entreprises locales par une utilisation
maximum des infrastructures guyanaise
port aéroport et par la création directe
et indir d' par exemple mademoiselle
Langlois ici présente fait partie de
l'équipe recrutée localement parce que
nous avons d'ors et déjà une une une une
antenne guyanaise qui gère les
opérations guyan donc nous cherchons à
recruter dors et déjà un maximum de
personnes
euh donc nous nous sommes d'ors et déjà
en cours de création de 25 emplois ch et
60 emplois indirects dont nous avons
connaissance ça c'est tout de suite hein
euh bon mais le plus le enfin
l'important c'est demain enfin c'est
demain c'est c'est le long terme mais
qu'il faut préparer dès
aujourd'hui alors je vais vous donner un
peu le donné sur le premier
axe pour que des gens soient capable de
travailler dans la branche pétrole il
faut en général qu'ils aient de 3 à 5
ans d'expérience pétrole pour être
qualifié dans ces métiers et jusqu'à 10
ans en fonction des métiers alors vous
voyez que si on ne faisait rien
aujourd'hui et que dans 3 à 5 ans on
décide de passer une phase de
développement je n'aurais pas les
personnes avec 3 5 ans
d'expérience donc il nous faut les
recruter
maintenant maintenant donc nous
recruterons maintenant des gens que nous
qualifierons pendant 3 5 ans dans nos
métiers hors de
guyan pour qu'il soit
qualifié lorsqu'on en aura besoin gu et
quand je dis nous nous avons déjà réuni
un certain nombre de de sociétés qui
sont prêtes à prendre ses engagements
aujourd'hui donc j'annonce très séement
qu'aujourd'hui on recrute des gens qui
serait futur
euh qui serait dans le projet gu s'il
aboutit à à un investissement et nous le
faisons sans la certitude que nous
investirons dans ce projet permettez-moi
de vous interrompre monsieur le
Président c'est tout à fait normal que
vous dans le champ de recroutement que
que la la la Guyenne soit privilégiée
mais considérz aussi qu'il y a une qu'il
y a une il y a aussi ce qu'on appelle
les
DFA département français d'Amérique et
qu' dirit que les autres départements la
la Marti qui ont les mêmes problèmes
guyan sont aussi parti prenantes dans
cette affaire alors un pilotage
politique et et il y a un pilotage
politique de cette activité d'ailleurs
donc qui permet justement d'aborder les
questions que vous
évoquez nous on génère du contenu on
appelle ça local mais local c'est c'est
sont largement les élus qui qui en
définissent
le le champ d'accord mais quand même la
nouvelle que je vous donne parce que
j'entends beaucoup de gens qui disent oh
de toute façon ils ne recruteront pas
ici je vous dis aujourd'hui on recrute
des gens pas dans les activités court
terme mais dans des activités long
terme et nous assumons le fait que
peut-être il n'y aura jamais de projet
et nous considérons que c'est notre
contribution à au développement de
capacités local voilà donc desjà qui
auront des qualifications des métiers
soit qu'ils emploieront dans des
activités pétrolières hors de Guyane
soit qu'ils sont transposable dans des
dans des industries présentes en guyen
d'accord et ça c'est quand même un
engagement très fort et je vous ai cité
quelques noms de sociétés qui ont d'ors
et déjà accepté cette règle schumberg
ifpndl je pourrais citer colast je
pourrais citer enfin le il y a
énormément de sociétés dans ceain
d'accord donc c'est quand même assez
novateur que nous anticipions des
recrutements alors ce sont des
recrutements àin de formation
qualification dans les métiers dont on a
besoin
de donc voilà ça c'est quand même une
vraie nouvelle parce que ça ça a été
défini il y a peu de
temps alors comment est-ce que c'est
piloté vous avez d'un côté les les
entreprises qui sont prêtes à à recruter
maintenant quand je dis maintenant c'est
le temps de faire vous avez la liste C
SAR par exemple puisque vous parlez des
Antilles est prête à former des au
métier pétrole dans sa raffinerie
chumberger W staff shell évidemment
nous-même nous sommes
recruteurs ça c'est la demande il y a
l'offre qu' nous faut structurer
c'est-à-dire évidemment identifier les
gens qui sont de
recrutable et c'est là qu'interviennent
bien sûr toutes les les organismes
aujourd'hui présents dans le monde
éducatif puis il faut une coordination
de l'ensemble une super agence qui qui
qui permettent de mettre en lien la
personne et l'opportunité d'accord mais
ce qui est important c'est le pilotage
parce que ce pilotage ce n'est pas
Chezelle qui l'opère c'est c'est là qu'
y a la mission de concertation locale
justement pour que soit prise en compte
les les
données politiques je dirais de
développement
local donc si si un certains type de
compétence n'est pas disponible en guyan
la collectivité peut décider de créer
des formations de ce type anguyan peut
décider de de s'intéresser au vivier
ultramarin ou métropolitain bien sûr je
j'ai pas de c'est pas nous qui ferons
de du pilotage dans ce sens là d'accord
donc ça c'est quand même très important
parce qu'à ma connaissance c'est la
première fois qu'on fédère sur un projet
avant même qui
soit officiel un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui se
prépare à à l'activité future
et j'insiste sont des recrutements en
CDI donc des Genson recr et qui sont
formés dans dans le cadre de leur
appartenance dans les sociétés
concernées par exemple un soudeur pour
prendre un exemple il faut 5 ans pour
qu'il soit qualifié pétrole donc il faut
qu'il parle anglais n alors c'est un le
monde du pétrole c'est un monde où
l'anglais est important donc c'est il y
aura probablement en tout cas pour
certains métiers une exigence un besoin
de dével un niveau de d'anglais minimum
ça fait ça fait partie des des éléments
du pilotage par
exemple
euh j'allais vous interroger justement
sur la partie formation et notamment
tout ce que vous envisagez mais j'en
parti ma réponse quand je vois le
rectorat pour moi le plus important est
le partenariat avec le rectorat parce
que ça peut provoquer vous savez des des
filières notamment au niveau des lycées
des des
pour ce monde pétrole parce que vous
savez que le le les différents rectorats
on se la pour consigne c'est de coller
au mieux leur formation aux différents
marchés d'aujourd'hui et ceux de et ceux
de demain donc je pense que je peux le
dire au nom de mes collègues la partie
partenariat est fondamentale et nous
nous vous encourageons à à continuer là
et très tôt absolument
donc
priorité mais pour aller dans le même
sens
euh je vous vous vous prenez là devant
nous un certain nombre d'engagements
maintenant dans la durée je pense que
encore une fois du point de vue de
l'intérêt général et de l'intérêt de ces
territoires des populations de ces
territoires si le dispositif qui est mis
en place n'est pas comment dire
opposable quoi c'està-dire si les
pouvoirs publics parce que les gens les
les personnes changent vous aujourd'hui
vous nous dites voilà mon équipe
travaillera comme ça j'ai j'ai une
expérience d'élu délégué au
développement économique sur des
territoires pas en Guyane mais la
première année la deuxème année ça va
après les directeurs changent et les
bonnes les bonnes paroles s'envol et et
et on va voir d'autres directeurs des
mêmes entreprises qui sont bien là qui
nous disent qu'il n'est pas possible de
recruter localement pour toutes sortes
de raisons et c'est c'est une vraie
question quel com je pense qu'il
faudrait trouver des des des cadres qui
qui garantissent la la la pérennité
voilà des conventions parce que sinon
ces
engagements peuvent voilà peuvent ne pas
à un moment donné s'arrêter dans leur
application
oui ceci c'est vrai que perz donc que
nous applaudissons tous donc cette
démarche même si nous resturons et
personnellement je resterai très
vigilant par rapport donc à ces aux
applications euh euh nous avons une
première expérience donc d'une activité
qui qui qui est majeure en guyan qui a
structuré la Guyane mais ce n'est qu'au
bout de 30 ans ce n'est que maintenant
que nous voyons donc une guyanisation de
l'emploi 30 ans plus tard euh je parle
du spatial et encore sont pas dans des
postes clés euh donc je crois que
évitons des erreurs euh passées euh donc
nous saluons cette anticipation euh par
rapport à une activité qui doit démarrer
euh euh d'ici 2019 vous dit 18 la phase
d'exploitation Voon je reprends vos
chiffres hein je faisais Noé vos dates
euh euh et donc nous resterons très
vigilant effectivement c'est comment
créer dans le cadre de qu'on va passer
donc cette fois-ci au au aux pyamides
d'exploiter euh donc au législateur
comment peut-être euh créer un cadre
particulier pour que une convention je
sais pas quelle forme juridique trouvé
pour que ces engagements soi soi soi
tenus et et et et vérifiés dans dans la
durée fait grands élus font partie du
pilotage dans la gouvernance donc
vraiment al là vraiment pour le coup
c'est un chantier qui est
largement qui est en cours donc moi je
suis vraiment preneur d'abord je je
demande un pilotage politique puisque
pour moi la la responsabilité de la
formation d'une population c'est quand
même une responsabilité de de l'État et
de la région c'est pas bien s mais je je
nous sommes capables de structurer une
demande et d'assurer un engagement long
terme chers collègues il s'agit d'un
engagement d'un président devant la
représentation nationale il pas lieu de
mettre ça vaut
engagement merci
oui
oui je pense
que vous y travaillez ce serait bien
qu'il un lien entre
l'autorisation que vous sollicitez
et cet engagement sur la formation en
terme d'affichage ce serait très très
important et c'est possible sous une
forme conventionnelle on peut
parfaitement imaginer que le le le
permis soit associé d'une d'une annexe
conventionnelle qui porte sur là-dessus
je pense que tout le monde il aurait
intérêt parce que je reviens à un point
de la discussion du du début qui est
l'information plus que l'information
l'association des populations à
l'élaboration de ce de ce grand projet
je pense que vous l'avez
entendu visiblement c'est une de vos
préoccupations mais elle n'est pas
forcément perçue et et est mise en acte
par les associations les les population
concerné donc je pense que en
en en inscrivant dans le marbre des
engagement sur la formation et qui ser
qui ferait partie finalement du projet
lui-même vous apporteriez déjà une
réponse très très concrète à cette
demande de participation au fense c'est
la meilleure préparer les les les
nouvelles générations à participer à
cette aventure c'est c'est c'est ce qu'
a mieux et je voulais aussi vous vous
posz une une question pour bien pour
bien cerner l'ampleur de de ce projet
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire comment
la Guyane se situe dans la stratégie
d'ensemble de votre de votre groupe
est-ce qu'il y a actuellement est-ce que
vous avez ailleurs des des forages ou
des des
des des forages exploratoires en cour et
dans quelle partie du monde oui je vais
vous montrer ça tout de suite je vais
utiliser une slide
voilà voilà nous sommes très présents au
Brésil je prendre la carte donc au
Brésil nous sommes très présents au
Guyana donc Georgetown et nous sommes
leaders dans le golf du
Mexique pour prendre des zones je dirait
voisine au sens large parce que les
distances sont sont évidemment
importantes et d'ailles
les données les données en terme de de
personnel d'emploi que je vais vous
communiquer viennent largement du Brésil
par que il y a une analogie je dirais
de de cas on va dire entre les deux à ce
stade je vais peut-être vous donner
peut-être un peu plus de détail sur le
type de de de profil de compéten de
formation et cetera alors d'abord il
faut voir que on parle d'une industrie
complète ça veut dire qu'il y a des
emplois de toute
qualification on ne parle pas de
d'emplois exclusivement de géologue on
ne parle pas d'emploi exclusivement de
gardienage et de de magasinier on parle
d'une spectre d'un spectre de métier
très très large hein donc de
formation professionnel à bac plus à
doctorat on va dire donc il y a vraiment
un un tras très très large éventail de
qualification
requise et ça c'est vrai dans
l'exploration dans l'exploration il y a
plus de de matière grise je dirais
concentration de matière grise que dans
l'exploitation mais c'est tout toutes C
ce spectre est présent tout au long donc
exploitation conception et
exploitation là je vous prends les
effectifs sur une sur une unité de
d'extraction au
large donc il y aurait à peu près au
large deux équipes de 70 personnes
Chelle et à terre une équipe de 20
personnes pour suivre cette activité
là donc voilà donner un ordre de
grandeur donc en gros 160 personnes
directement associées à l'activité
d'exploitation là je vous parle pas de
d'activité d'études de concession
d'exploration juste la purement
exploitation
du
champ en général pour un emploi d'chelle
on génère qure emplois indirects mais
qure emplois ind direct de de
spécialistes du
pétrole
support donc de maintenance industriel
pétrole on va dire donc des gens qui
sont employés par des sociétés de type
schumberger Hendel maintenance
industrielle
OUC ce genre de société que vous
retrouvez probablement au CG par exemple
c'est le même type
sûement et puis il y a le les emplois
induits hein donc
euh donc et là on parle de ratio
de de de de un induit pour un indirect
plus
indirect ça c'est très statistique et ça
relève pas d'une analyse
extraordinairement détaillée sur ce
projet
puis dans les métiers dans les métiers
alors voyez des exemples de
métiers voilà un éventail de métier
voyez des marins de la maintenance des S
d'Ur des chaudronniers électriciens
mécanicien chef de chantier logisticien
et puis des gens dans le logement dans
le transport dans le médical dans les
loisirs dans dans l'hôtellerie et
cetera donc et si vous regardez
l'ensemble de ces métiers les capacités
actuelles en guyan ne sont pas forcément
tout très développé par exemple vous
trouverez pas facilement de sou d'or et
de chaudronier en guyan aujourd'hui
parce qu'il n'y a pas une tradition
industrielle extrêmement développé et
ceux qui l'ont sont totalement employés
au au Centre Spatial guyan par contre il
y a d'autres il y a d'autres secteurs
où et il y a d'autres secteurs où
l'offre est largement
disponible voilà al ce que je vais vous
montrer c'est un peu les type de profil
voyz pas exemp un
mécanicien sur
plateforme doit avoir 4 5 ans
d'expérience typiquement formation DUT
BTS donc là typiquement ce sont des gens
qu'il faut recruter par
anticipation un leader quelqu'un qui
soit chef responsable là on parle de 15
ans
d'expérience donc il est probable que
qu'on démarrera avec quelqu'un qui vient
de l'extérieur pour cette partie mais
avec l'idée que on crée le
le système qui permette que ces gensl
soi effectivement locau dans quelques
années donc voilà typiquement
typiquement la cible pour les action de
recrutement bientôt c'est
celle on va dire B+ 2 à spécialiser
certifi là je parle d'emploi chez
nous mais vous avez aussi des profils
cap bop et cetera donc il y a quand même
une gamme de de de formation très
intéressante d'un point de vue d'un
point de vue
social alors ça veut dire que c'est
aussi un moyen de réinsérer des gens ce
n'est pas qu'un c'est pas seulement une
industrie qui peut recruter des diplômés
et les qualifier pétrole mais c'est
aussi une industrie qui peut réinsérer
puisque tous les métiers ne sont pas des
métiers à très forte qualification
bon enfin
voilà juste juste donc un aperçu un peu
du travail qui est en cours de de
développement et que je et que je
présente dans les réunions publiques
dans le cadre de la demande
d'autorisation de déclaration
d'ouverture de travaux sur le sur le
volet retombé local le deuxième point
très important c'est la stimulation du
tissu économique
local par parce que vous voyez bien que
pour pour les métiers indirects et
induit
il je dirais qu'il est assez naturel de
penser que des entrepreneurs et
entreprise guyanais puissent fournir une
grosse partie de la
demande donc en fait en fait ce qu'il
faut c'est que ces industries qui sont
souvent des
petites industries locales soit
accompagné pour qu'il puisse répondre
aux appels d'offre par exemple je prends
l'exemple des métiers de bouche ou de
d'aliment d'alimentaire plateforme il y
a des cahés des charges extrêmement
strictes puisque vous ne pouvez pas
contaminer
l'équipage donc il y a des normes de la
profession extrêmement stricte sur la
qualité alimentaire et cetera bon il
faut simplement accompagner les
entreprises locales pour qu'elles soient
à ce standard là ce tout à fait possible
mais il faut le faire
euh bon là j'ai pris un exemple il y a
un certain nombre d'exemples de ce type
il faut simplement accompagner gens pour
qu'il soi en mesure de répondre à la
demande et puis évidemment il faut que
contractuellement et cetera nous
incitions nos propres fournisseurs à se
fournir localement donc ça c'est l'objet
d'un deuxième groupe de travail
structurer un peu de la MAN avec un
pilotage une gestion de l'offre et de la
demande l'axe 3 c'est la coopération
scientifique il faut que nous
développions une connaissance
approfondie du milieu puisque nous
sommes là si si le projet est un succès
pour longtemps et comme je vous dit que
notre politique c'est zéro accident et
impact minimum il faut qu'on se donne
les moyens d'acquérir la connaissance
pour ça et donc nous avons lancé un
Groupement d'Intérêt Scientifique avec
CNRS etrè comme les deux piliers mais
tout un ensemble de laboratoire et
institut
autour et l'idée c'est que très
rapidement on finance des thèses qui ont
des durées de vie de 3 ans pour
commencer à établir
ce cet ensemble de
connaissance et puis bien sûr participer
et àir des études déjà en
cours et le 4è axe c'est l'action en mer
comme nous serons en mer nous aurions
tons toutes nos actions à but non
directement lucratif si vous voulez en
mer donc c'est le soutien du secteur
pêche c'est le plan de de développement
d'activités maritime secours en mer euh
tourisme c'est l'aide au pêcheurs pour
qu'il y ait une une coopérative d'achat
de matériel c'est euh c'est la recherche
peut-être de moteurs qui sont mieux
adaptés aux EAU guyanaises c'est c'est
c'est ce que je résume par action en mer
d'accord et qui fait l'objet aussi d'un
groupe dont c'est la finalité et qui
associe là très largement les pêcheurs
et tous les tous les participants à
l'action en mer donc voilà les quatre AX
qui sont d'ors et
déjà
développés pour que ce projet a des
retombé et une intégration locale
maximum hein alors c'est un peu tôt pour
que je vous donne des des résultats
tangibles mais c'est l'orientation qui
est prise qui est communiquée et sur
laquelle on travaille je travaille la
semaine prochaine so Caren par
exemple autiste Maurice pour ma propre
gouverne question rapide combien de de
types d'exploitation vous avez en terme
de volume hein euh je suppose que c'est
c'est lié à la aux réserves de pétrole
au réserves découvertees combien de
types et du plus petit type au plus
grand combien il faut en moyenne de
d'employer et ben je vous ai donné la
les chiffres que je vous communique
c'est j'ai pris un projet de même ordre
donc c'est moyen
oui près oui parce que évidemment
le la réalité dépendra beaucoup du
projet qui qui sera effectivement
développé mais combien de types vous
avez en terme de volume je veux dire
d'installation les installations de ce
type on en a développé une vingtaine
dans le monde ce
type 20 productif aujourd'hui plus un
certain nombre de projets en cours mais
il y en a de plus importantes terme
d'installation c'est
pas la quantité de personne sur un sur
un équipement ne dépend pas de la
quantité produite parce que que vous
ayez des des tuyaux plus petits ou plus
gros ne change pas le nombre
marginalement le nombre de personnes
requises pour opérer c'est pour ça que
ces chiffres sont quand même
relativement bord de grandeur mais mais
mais là je parle d'un champ je vous ai
dit qu'on explorait plusieurs réservoir
donc si vous étiez très optimiste
peut-être qu' aurit deux champs peutêtre
plus peut-être plus très bien on a
compris je passe la parole tout de suite
à monsieur le rapporteur oui merci donc
nous avons pris bonne note donc
concernant la question de de la
formation et de l'emploi on va pas
aborder aujourd'hui la question des
recettes fiscal c'est un débat qui est
davantage
législatif sur cette question mais je va
revenir sur la question
infrastructurelle notamment au niveau
des des ports d'attache alors où est-ce
que vous en êtes dans vos discussions
avec l'institution régionale ou bien la
chambre de commerces et d'industrie je
sais que la première fois lors de la
première phase exploration vous avez
utilisé le ou les ports le port du
Surinam peut-être le port du
deort de trinid pardon est-ce que cette
annéeci vous allez également utiliser le
port de Suriname ou enfin concrètement
qu'est-ce qui est prévu dans dans le cas
de la phase d'exploitation si nous
sommes toujours dans l'obligation de
d'aller au Surinam pour la deuxè phase
d'exploration alors pour l'exploration
aujourd'hui la base primaire c'est
Trinidade et la base secondaire c'est
Cayen donc par rapport au forage dans
l'an dernier nous avons beaucoup plus
d'activités à Cayen à beaucoup plus
parce qu'il n'avait pas la dernière fois
donc c'est nous nous avons réservé 2000
m² de d'espace sur le port et euh nous
assurons par exemple les les
avitaillements en en en carburant depuis
Cayenne alors que ceci se faisait depuis
Trinidad ou ou Paramaribo en 2011
d'accord donc il y a déjà une montée en
charge de Cayenne après les nous sommes
contraints par la disponibilité du port
au aujourd'hui dans dans le programme
donc ce que nous allons faire c'est
démarrer avec la disponibilité qui nous
est donné et puis nous verrons au fil de
l'eau si on peut utiliser Cayenne de
façon plus importante al pour pr à terme
mais à terme si si on on part d'une
exploitation en mer un jour il faudra
une infrastructure
portuaire
pétrole en guyan c'est une
infrastructure de logistique des
installations
future alors est-ce que c'est un
problème de déficit infrastructurel
j'imagine mais estce qu'il y a aussi un
effet coût également
entre le le Surinam Trinidade et la Guan
non non Cayen l'emporte Cayen c'est à
150 km Trinidad c'est
à je sais pas
4000 je je vais pas donner un chiffre je
vais me tromper mais c'est loin donc il
est toujours plus intéressant d' CEN pas
forcément très loin du sudam alors par
mais en fait de touteçon
Cayen a toutes les devrait être
compétitif en terme purement maritime
d'accord et donc à ce niveau il y a déjà
des échange
avec l'institution régionale pour la
réalisation d'un port exclusivement
dédié au non parce qu'on n'est pas
encore dans une phase où on pense qu'on
va investir dans le projet futur par
contre on va devoir mener dans l'année
je pense des réflexions sur
une une extension temporaire de de de
grade de canne c'estàd quelque chose qui
permet de faire
plus mais qui ne soit pas encore
l'investissement lourd de
reconfiguration du port pour appotement
quoi les appotements ouais de ce genre
c'est pas encore défini mais je pense
qu'il faudra faire dans la deuxième
moitié d'année ces études qui
permettront de
comprendre nos besoins pour la
suiteère question question non non mais
j'ai une dernière question et là je Rens
la discussion donc
introductive posé
par le sénateur donc les sénateurs de
l'Hexagone est-ce que la Chelle va
s'inscrire dans
une stratégie de de de filières de de la
production on s'inscrit dans dans un
cadre virtueux hein donc après
l'exploration on découvre donc du
pétrole on va passer à la phase
d'exploitation est-ce qu'on va est-ce
que donc votre société va s'inscrire
donc qui
sera leader donc de de cette chaîne donc
de cette filière de la production
jusqu'au raffinage et là je reviens donc
au sujet donc du début de de séance par
rapport donc à la à la région donc de
petit courouronne est-ce que ça fait
partie de vos projets dans vos
stratégies de de développement ou bien
est-ce que vous allez
segmenter cette filière
alors Shelle est déjà un leader mondial
intégré c'estàdire que nous sommes
présents de la production jusqu'à la
vente nous sommes le plus gros
commerçant mondial de produits
pétroliers et nous sommes un des plus
gros raffineurs mondiaux donc la filière
raffinage du groupe Shelle est une
activité très
significative par contre le site de
petit cour ne s'inscrit pas dans les
orientations long terme pour des raisons
spécifique il y a en bass scè deux
autres raffineries beaucoup plus
importantes en taille je pense de
société
concurrente
et Petit Couronne n'est pas de taille de
notre point de vue à à être concurrente
de ces de ces sites là d'où notre
choix de de d'investir dans d'autres
projets que dans ce site de petitcouron
et nous avons été et nous avions un
acquéreur qui à l'époque était tout à
fait qualifié pour développer cette
activité là donc donc voilà donc c'est
donc nous sommes déjà une société
intégrée par contre le choix des lieux
de de raffinage dépend d'un certain
nombre de critères de marché et nous
n'avions pas en France le marché qui ne
justifiait que nous opérions une
raffinerie par exemple nous n'avons pas
de un réseau de station service en
France de l'ampleur de celui que de
certains de nos
concurrents
le si je faisais un raccourci extrême
le la raison pour laquelle les sociétés
en général se retirent de France en
terme de raffinage c'est parce que la
France est un des rares pays au monde où
les les carburants ne sont pas vendus
par des pétroliers sont vendus par des
grandes
surfacestp le gouvernement conditionne
le permis
d'exploitation par rapport à à Petit
Couronne ce serait complètement
illégal je veux dire c'est je ne voit
rien dans un état de droit qui
justifierait ce genre de
démarche c'est tout
simplement ce sont deux choses
complètement
indépendantes nous respectons la loi
nous répondons aux attentes aux
critères technique économique et cetera
et donc
ça devient de la
discrimination TR bien
ça euh je voulais quand même un souci
hein j'ai un petit problème mais je
pense que dans T les cas favorable
d' d'une abondance de pétrole est-ce
comment se positionne à SCE qui sera
alimenté par la raffinerie de la par la
par le gisement de la
Guadeloupe déjà quelque part
approvisionne le carburant pour
l'activité
là non non mais de l'alimentation parce
que vous savez que le pétrole bout de
Sara vient de la merre du Nord ce qui
nous revient très cher à nous les
antillis les guadais ouz le pétrole même
le carburant donc c'est n pas faut
inutile de penser que en trouvant du
pétrole pas trop lourd paraî-il en
Guyane on pourrait alimenter le la SARA
ce qui permettrait de faire tomber un
peu les coûts de
production ça c'est le genre de chose
qui devra développé en temps utile en
fonction en fonction des des données de
la qualité et cetera donc ça mais c'est
le genre de projet qui peut avoir un
sens bien sûr mais qui qu'on ne peut pas
anticiper aujourd'hui d'accord on y
réfléchit
oui oui monsieur le Président euh je je
reviens sur le l'échéance de 2019 je je
suppose que c'est fonction euh des
travaux et des programmations euh que
vous préparez que vous avez fixé cette
échéance est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner plus de détails euh et euh est-ce
qu'il est permis de penser que d'ici
euh il y aurait une une
étape au cours de laquelle on on aura
plus de certitude quant à la réalisation
quant à la concrétisation euh de ce de
ce projet d'accord il y a deux
conditions à remplir à priori comme ça
pour être simple c'est l'aspect
géologique il faut qu'il y ait le
pétrole en quantité en
qualité suffisante et puis qu'il soit
exploitable de façon rationnelle qu'il
soit techniquement expable et le
deuxième volet c'est celui-là hein c'est
l'aspect stabilité fiscale juridique et
cetera parce que si mes données sont
bonnes je crois qu'il y a eu un
changement une évolution fiscale tous
les 13 jours tous les 13 jours entre
2000 dernières 5 années dans les
dernières 5 années donc vous imaginez
bien que confronté à une situation où la
fiscalité peut évoluer tous les 13 jours
il est difficile d'imaginer un un
investissement de cet ordre sans un
minimum de discussion sur l'aspect
stabilité donc ce sera pour moi un des
très grands facteurs
de de décision d'investir ou
pas les conditions globales de stabilité
fiscale et réglementaire aussi puisque
nous sommes dans un pays où on peut
changer assez facilement les
réglementations j'entends technique qui
fait que ce qui était au standard un
jour nit plus le donc ça c'est un très
très gros volet mais si ça se fait je
dirais que les forages les quatre
forages dont j'ai parlé plus d'autres
qu'il faudra
faire plus cette discussion on peut dire
qu'il peut y avoir une investissement
dans 2 ou 3 ans peu hein après ça c'est
dire voilà nous investtis comp tenu de
toute cet ensemble de données de contrat
et de
négociation nous investissons après il
faut le temps de
construire donc vous compter encore 2 ou
3 ans donc vous voyez je suis à 4
euh et puis faut faut démarrer euh
encore quelques années donc voyez c'est
pour ça que je vous ai dit un peu comme
ça très bien euh monsieur le Président
euh nous avons bien avancé et nous avons
une question à voir les derniè dernier
point à voir les conditions nécessaires
à la conduite du projet je vous propose
donc puisque nous n'en savons pas
trop nous revoyons par la suite au
moment vous aurez suffisamment
d'éléments pour nous en dire plus nous
vous êtes d'accord ah je suis absolument
honoré de venir régulièrement
lâ maintenant vous avez compris ça donc
nous étions très plaisir à voir vous
recevoir ici à vous accueillir ici
échanger avec vous et et vous vos propos
l'échange d'aujourd'hui nous permet
d'illustrer ce dont nous disions depuis
longtemps que c'est que l'outre maire
n'est pas UniCAP pour la l'Hexagone pour
la France et un atout par sa
biodiversité par sa présence sous les S
trois océans trois continents par sa par
sa zone et c'est c'est ressources bien
sûr et sa jeunesse toute chose sa
jeunesse bon qui montre bien que ce que
nous avions avancé était bien chos de
vrai et c'est pour cette raison quand on
a parlé de petite couronne je vous ai
dit que c'est un gourmandise que je vois
le flux vercé au MO vous savez dans non
plus dans are histoire dans notre
histoire l'histoire de la Caraïbe
département les richesses sortaient de
la Caraïbe pour venir à la France après
on nous a on nous a complexé en nous
disant nous sommes des sommes des
danseuses de la République nous sommes
des chats lge et on s'est employé à nous
montrer que nous coûtions cher à la
métropole aujourd'hui nous sommes en
train de démontrer que nous sommes un
atout important et ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui va dans la voie que la
démonstration que nous voulons opérer
donc vous serez encore bienvenu au Sénat
et je vous remercie de la contribution
que vous avez apporté aujui au débat
concernant le pétrole la CA du pétrole
dans les EAU guadè je remercie et à
bientôt c'est la fin de cette audition
merci à vous d'avoir suivi les travaux
de la délégation sénatoriale à l'outrem
pour revoir cette audition notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très bonne
journée à
tous